Boogers, Alter, Boogers.
Nicht, keine erste Wahl.
Hört mal auf.
Das muss ich schon bei 300.000 Abos.
Wobei, eigentlich muss ich nicht.
Weil ich hab das nur mal irgendwo auf dem Stream gesagt.
Das ist ja nicht...
Ich hab's ja nicht mal auf YouTube offiziell gesagt.
Da muss ich gar nix.
Lull.
Wuppe Lull.
Da muss ich gar nix machen.
Lautstärke und so.
Passt.
Wie immer.
Weil das ist ja typisch Windows.
Das gerne einfach mal verstellt, ne?
Letztens Sound okay, heute Sound kacke.
Weil Windows-Logik.
Übrigens, hier, Windows, ne?
Ich hab letztens gesucht, wo man...
Ich hab letztens versucht zu finden, warum mein Mikrofon nicht ging.
Es ging ums Verrecken, ging mein Mikro nicht.
Und wisst ihr, woran das lag?
Ratet mal.
Ratet mal, woran das lag.
Da kommt ihr nie drauf.
Das war so ein typischer Windows-Crap.
Was witzig war...
Also, ich meine, wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen Windows-Flame.
Windows-Flame kann nie schaden.
Wisst ihr überhaupt, wie kompliziert das mittlerweile ist,
in das Menü zu kommen, wo man wirklich Sound-Settings einstellen kann?
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ihr einstellen wollt,
welche Frequenz...
Ähm, nicht Frequenz, wie heißt denn das?
Welche Abtastrate euer Sound verwenden soll.
Was recht prakt...
Also was wichtig ist,
wenn man zum Beispiel per optischen...
per TOS-Link an einem Audio-Interface dran ist.
Wisst ihr, wo das mittlerweile geht?
Passt mal auf hier.
Ich hoffe mal, ich finde das überhaupt.
Mikro war deaktiviert.
Nee, nee, nee.
Mikro ging, Mikro ging.
Also, man muss jetzt hier rechts draufklicken.
Mik... Nee.
Nee, Moment.
Muss jetzt hier Open Sound Settings machen.
Sound Control Panel.
Dann geht das olle Ding auf.
Ja, Teamilius, das ist gar nicht so schlecht, was du da vermutest.
Privacy-Einstellung fürs Mikrofon.
So.
Und dann kann man das aufmachen.
Ähm...
So, und dann habe ich hier nachgeguckt
und habe damals festgestellt,
dass hier mein Mikrofon war aktiviert und alles gut,
aber es hat keinen Ausschlag gehabt.
Das ging nicht, ja?
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Dann kann sich das Mikrofon mal entscheiden.
Angeblich ist das voll leise, ne?
Angeblich ist das voll leise.
Allerdings OBS sagt, es ist fast schon zu laut.
Wo man sich sagen muss, was?
Muss das jetzt irgendjemand verstehen?
Egal, wie noch aus Logik.
Scheiß drauf.
So.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt, ey,
wenn ich hier in die Settings gehe
und, äh,
listen this device mache,
pass auf, dann gibt es ein Echo,
muss man jetzt aufpassen.
So, Echo, Echo.
Echo, Echo, Echo.
Äh, dann hat...
Oh, geh aus.
Dann hat das funktioniert.
Aber es hat nicht normal funktioniert.
So, und da habe ich echt...
Also, in meiner Leitung, bis ich dieses Menü hier gefunden habe...
Ach ja, übrigens.
Wer sich fragt, warum er teilweise Sound-Aussetzer hat oder...
ähm...
Das ist...
Das ist knistert, knastert, wie auch immer.
Knistert.
Beim optischen Soundausgang.
Da muss man nämlich hier auf Playback gehen.
Auf Digital Audio.
Und dann auf...
Das hier ist...
Das ist Fake.
Das stimmt nicht.
Man muss auf Advanced.
Und guckt hier.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist...
Das ist Microsoft Big Brain.
Ja?
Supported Formats.
48 Kilohertz.
Default Format.
44,1 Kilohertz.
Wo ist die Logik, Microsoft?
Wo ist die Logik?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Aber so funktioniert es.
Anders funktioniert es nicht.
Das heißt, in dieses Menü muss man sich irgendwie vorarbeiten, dass man das ändern
kann.
So.
Und zumindest das Problem, was ich hatte mit meinem Windows, warum das mit dem Mikrofon
nicht funktioniert hat, war...
Äh...
Ich meine, vor allem, was ist das schon wieder für ein komisches Menü?
Wofür ist das überhaupt da?
Ähm...
Scheiße.
Wo war das denn jetzt?
Das ist übrigens voll doppelt, ne?
Es gibt hier diese Settings.
Es gibt diese Settings.
Es gibt hier unten die Settings und den Mixer.
Ach du Scheiße.
Wo war das denn jetzt?
Privacy Settings für Mikro...
Für...
Für Mikrofon.
Ja.
Microphone Privacy Settings.
Und da stand...
Allow apps to access your microphone.
Stand auf Off.
Wer denkt denn daran, dass deswegen sein Mikrofon nicht geht?
Aber...
gefunden habe, weil der Witz war ja,
auf meinem Streaming-Account hat alles
funktioniert. Ich wollte mit dem Eax
irgendwas, irgendwas, nee, nee, nee, nicht mal mit dem
Eax, mit dem M-Core wollte ich damals
eine Runde Discord labern und es hat
ums Verrecken nicht funktioniert. Es ging einfach nicht.
Und da bin ich dann extra auf einen Streaming-Account
umgelockt, dass ich mit dem labern konnte
im Discord, weil es auf dem Haupt-Account ums Verrecken
nicht funktioniert hat. Bis ich dann irgendwann mal
drauf gekommen bin, weil ich genauso
wie hier einfach mal ein Microphone gesucht habe
und zufällig hier reingegangen bin,
dass es hier auf Off steht.
Warum, warum, was, warum?
Und vor allem, es gibt ja immer,
du kannst ja hier sagen, ähm, in Sound
kannst du irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht, wo da, hier,
hier kannst du sagen, set up your microphone
oder set up a micro...
Nee, kannst du nicht.
Äh, nee.
Fix your sound problems.
Nee, fuck.
Wo ist das? Man kann so einen komischen Assistent
starten, man kann irgendwie so einen
komischen Assistent starten, der einem
versucht, das Mikrofon einzurichten.
Und der Assistent ist abgestürzt.
Der ist immer abgekackt, der Assistent.
Also ich meine, es wäre ja irgendwie
sinnvoll, ja, wenn
Windows das umgedreht machen würde,
ein Icon, so nach dem Motto
hier, Mikrofon ist an
und ein Icon, hallo,
Mikrofon ist ausgeschaltet,
nur dass du es einfach siehst.
Aber du siehst, vergiss es,
du siehst das nicht. Also ganz, ganz,
ganz, ganz, ja, MonkaVin.
Echt, also.
Ich weiß manchmal echt nicht,
was mit Microsoft abgeht, wer sich sowas ausdenkt.
Es ist ja auch schon grausam, wenn du dir das hier
anguckst, teilweise, wie viele alte,
richtig alte, mittelalte und
neue und ganz neue
User-Interfaces unter Windows gemixt sind.
Und außerdem
denkt sich ja Microsoft gerne was,
ähm, gerne was
Neues aus, wie ihre Oberfläche aussehen muss.
Du hast mich im vorletzten
Video mit deiner Microtech-Sucht angesteckt,
die Router sind mega nice,
sagt der
Luxi-Zu?
Luki-Zu?
Ähm, ja,
die sind mega nice, vor allem für das Geld, wäre cool,
wenn du mal ein bisschen Router-OS zeigst.
Würde mir auch gerne einen Router, du kannst,
ähm, die haben, wenn du dich, wenn du,
wenn du dich interessierst dafür, wie das aussieht,
die haben eine Router-OS-Demo, die ist
ziemlich praktisch.
Ja, äh,
einfach auf OK drücken.
Hier kannst du dir das angucken.
Ja, kannst du, kannst du
rumbasteln.
Ich kann schlecht meine Router-Settings
im Stream zeigen, ich weiß nämlich nicht,
ob da nicht irgendwas drinnen steht, weil ich
nicht will, dass man das sieht.
Äh, im Prinzip ist Windows auch gar nicht so
schlimm. Die Details
sind das, was in Windows sagt.
Gibt es heute auch ein Hannah Montana
Linux? Wann ist es, wann wurde das
zuletzt geupdatet?
Wann wurde das zuletzt geupdatet?
Also ganz,
ganz wieder.
So, ähm, übrigens, ich hab
ein richtig, ich hab ein richtig cooles Video letztens
auf YouTube gesehen. Der hat
die Geschichte
von Mario Kart Rainbow Road
hat der irgendwie 45 Minuten
alle, alle Time Trail,
Trail, Trail, Time
Trial? Time Trial,
ne? Ähm,
Rekorde 45 Minuten lang auf
jeder Rainbow Road Strecke
von, von Mario Kart gezeigt.
Ich mein, das klingt erstmal hyper, hyper,
hyper-resonance-lieber. Das wär echt spannend.
Dein Mikro-Tick steht aber
hinter dem Unity-Media-Router,
beziehungsweise, Fritz, hinter dem Unity-Media-Router,
ja, ja, ja, leider, ne? Das kommt ja,
da kommst du ja nicht drumherum.
Kabelmodem kaufen mach ich nicht.
Ist mir auch zu, ist mir auch zu, zu blöd,
noch ein extra Gerät hinzustellen.
Ähm,
ich mein, es gibt jetzt ja
seit neuestem wieder, hab ich gelesen,
von Tritec diese,
oder Tritec, wie spricht man überhaupt aus?
Gibt es ja jetzt,
gibt es wieder ein Kabel, ein Kabelmodem
zu kaufen bei denen?
Gar nicht, welches das war.
Haben die das überhaupt hier irgendwo drinne
stehen?
Das da, ha? Ne.
Allerdings, ähm,
weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt von dem.
Aber ich hab keinen Bock, noch ein extra Gerät hinzustellen.
Guck mal, es ist
irgendwie total beknackt,
nur um, um
nen theoretisch saubere,
saubere Riss-Setup zu haben,
ähm, drei Geräte,
drei Geräte zu betreiben, irgendwie.
Für was, für was ist ein zweiter Router sinnvoll?
Naja, gut, wenn man einen gescheiten Router haben will.
Fritzbox ist kein gescheiter Router.
Wenn man was mit WLAN-Unterstützung zum Beispiel haben will, ja.
Äh, was essentiell dafür ist,
wenn man mehrere WLANs haben will,
außer dieses komische Gäste-WLAN von der Fritzbox.
Ähm, die Fritzbox
ist ein ziemlicher Scheiß-Router. Was die Fritzbox
gut macht, ist, die Fritzbox
ist ein super Multifunktionsgerät.
Cable-Shooter.
Was ist mit denen los?
Und wenn ich ginge, dass er halt so will,
Ihh, es ist Windows 98!
The fuck?
Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie das,
wie das von denen hieß.
Aber da seh ich nicht ein. Und zumindest ich mach das so,
ähm, wie gesagt, ich werde
demnächst umgestellt von Unity Media
von 100 Down und 5 Up auf
400 Down und 40 Up.
Und ich werd bei denen gleich sagen, ich will meine eigene,
meine eigene Fritzbox verwenden.
Dann fällt schon mal dieses komische Technicolor
Unity Media Router weg.
Das Ding ist übelster Crap.
Das ist wirklich, das ist das Ding hier.
Da hatten bestimmt schon Leute,
da hatten bestimmt schon Leute Freude mit,
mit diesem tollen Gerät hier. Das da!
Alter, so ein Crap hab ich selten
gesehen, ey.
Das ist wirklich das räudigste Modem aller Zeiten,
was es gibt.
Also das ist, das ist
abartig.
Der WLAN ist eh ausgeschaltet bei dem Ding.
Deswegen werd ich's jetzt so machen,
ähm, ich, wenn die mich
umstellen, werd ich den auch gleich
sagen, ich will einen eigenen, eigenen Router betreiben.
Darf man ja, ja, ist kein Ding.
Also mittlerweile, es ist ja sogar
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, dass sie das einem erlauben müssen.
Dann werd ich mir eine eigene Kabel-Fritzbox
dran machen, muss ich noch bestellen.
Weil ich brauch die halt für, für, ähm,
DECT, DECT-Telefone.
Ansonsten, für sonst eigentlich nix.
Und
dahinter kommt dann mein MikroTik-Router und ich werd's
halt so machen, dass die
Fritzbox macht halt den Ausgang zu Unity Media,
also sprich die Fritzbox macht NAT ins Internet
und der, äh,
MikroTik-Router, der macht halt
das, was er gut kann, der routet halt einfach,
so.
Mit Default-Gateway der Fritzbox.
Dann hast du nur einmal NAT an der Stelle, wo's sein muss,
nämlich am Ausgang.
Die, der Uplink-Port
zur Fritzbox, den stell ich quasi
dann auf die Geschwindigkeit ein, die mein Internetanschluss
hat, also sprich, äh,
400 runter, 40 ab.
Braucht man für die, das braucht man für die Warteschlange, weil man
wirklich QoS machen will.
Ja, und so dann, dann
funktioniert das auch, so. Bring ich schon 125
Leute am Start, 5 Minuten nachdem ich, äh, wie lang?
Hier, 15 Minuten nachdem ich
Stream gestartet hab, das ist massiv
pock.
Ich hab übrigens letztens noch einen Subscriber
vergessen, fällt mir gerade auf.
Und zwar,
ich hab letztens vergessen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob er da ist, ich muss
grad mal Streamlabs aufmachen.
Und zwar, ich hab vergessen,
den, ähm,
einmal den
Febe, Febe 2, Febe 2,
für zwei Monate ist er schon dabei, ich weiß,
ich weiß nicht, ob er da ist.
Ich will's mir nicht vorwerfen lassen,
dass ich Leute übersehe.
Und, ähm, ein, und vor
17 Stunden, da war ich definitiv im
Bett und hab geschlafen,
ähm, der Cube
0, der Cube Zero ist auch
am Start. Nice.
Huge Brain heute.
Wir starten heute mit Brain
schon ein bisschen größer als normal.
Keine Amazon Prime Werbung.
Welche Amazon Prime Werbung?
Ah, mach ich später, ich muss erstmal
eine Weile online bleiben.
Was geht mir da eigentlich YouTube wieder für komische Dinger?
Geht ja noch. Die YouTube-Empfehlungen
hier gehen ja noch irgendwie, die sind noch relativ neutral.
Sagt euch Leute, die YouTube-Empfehlungen, was sind
das da oben? Bin ich
eingeloggt mit irgendwas?
Ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen, ich hab keine Ahnung,
mit was ich da eingeloggt bin.
Warum, warum bin ich da
eingeloggt? MonkaS?
Hahaha!
Lol! Ich kann's euch
zeigen, mit was ich eingeloggt bin.
Hahaha!
Mit meinem, mit
meinem Fake, mit meiner
Fake-E-Mail-Adresse, die ich
letztens erstellt habe.
Ich hab doch letztens eine Fake-E-Mail-Adresse
gestellt, um meinen Versandtracker zu testen.
Gleich, das ist halt,
das ist halt so diese typische Google-Geschichte.
Du machst eine Sache, ne?
Du machst eine Sache und bist sofort
auf allen Plattformen connected
und, und sonst was.
Vorgestern.
Lustig.
So, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Hier ist Settings.
History.
Clear.
Letzten 7 Tage.
Alles.
Bam.
Und jetzt machen wir zu.
Jetzt machen wir auf.
Und nun bin ich nicht
mehr eingeloggt, Alter.
Warum bin ich im...
YouTube, was ist da los?
Google, was ist da los?
Warum bin ich noch eingeloggt,
obwohl ich die History gelöscht hab?
Was ist das?
Was Chrome log... Was zum Teufel ist Chrome
Login? Ih!
Was ist das?
Wo...
Wo kommt das her? Und warum ist das standardmäßig an?
Alter, die sind hartnäckig.
Die sind wirklich hartnäckig. Okay.
Sign out. Bam.
Reload.
Ah! Jetzt ist es weg.
Jetzt ist alles wieder weg.
Okay, nice. Perfekt.
Es ist schlimmer als gedacht.
Das war die Horizon 3000 Boost-Umfrage.
Eigentlich müssen wir
den Auer gucken wieder.
Den Auer. Den Auer können wir nachher gucken.
Ähm...
Anschauen.
Na gut.
Wenn ihr sagt, dass wir das jetzt anschauen müssen, müssen wir das jetzt anschauen.
Da muss ich aber erst mal
die Ärzte ausmachen.
Sonst hören wir vom Auer nix.
Okay.
Gucken wir uns mal an, was der Auer zu sagen hat.
Hallo zusammen und herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren Video.
Auf dieses Video haben sehr viele von euch gewartet,
denn heute schauen wir uns
die Ergebnisse meiner
Horizon 3000 Boost-Umfrage an.
Ich hab in den letzten zwei bis drei Tagen
extrem viel Zeit damit...
Ich hab so ne 1080p Bildschirm, aber Leute,
ich würd schon sagen, dass wir 4K gucken, oder?
Wir gucken 4K.
Das bringt zwar nix,
aber einfach das Gefühl 4K zu gucken
ist schon nice.
...verbracht die ganzen Daten auszuwerten.
Das ist unfassbar viel.
Außerdem sieht der Auer auch gleich schärfer aus
auf 4K. Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt.
Eigentlich sollte das keinen Unterschied machen,
aber der sieht schärfer aus.
Vielleicht bessere Bitrate.
Stört dich dieses riesige UI nicht,
wenn du Chrome im Vollbild hast?
Nö.
...viel, was ich daraus ziehen konnte.
Das heißt, kommt jetzt ein bisschen später,
als ich eigentlich wollte.
Ich hab, das sag ich auch im Voraus schon mal,
auch schon mit AMD über diese Daten gesprochen,
weil es natürlich,
wie man sieht, für AMD.
Oh, jetzt wird AMD gebasht.
Ich will da AMD gegenüber auch offen sein,
denn es geht ja nicht darum, AMD fertig zu machen,
sondern es geht darum, quasi dieses Problem zu lösen.
Und wenn AMD aus diesen Daten auch was ziehen kann,
dann ist das gut, keine Sorge,
da werden keine persönlichen Daten weitergegeben.
Da werden sie eben wieder vorwerfen,
dass er voll der krasse AMD-Hater ist.
Das werfen ihm die ganzen Fanboys eh immer vor.
Dabei hat der Ryzen
im einen oder im letzten Video
so übelst gelobt, ne?
Es wurde lediglich weitergegeben,
für eine CPU, auf welchem Board,
mit welchem Takt lief.
Und da können keine persönlichen Daten
irgendwie nachvollzogen werden,
deswegen, das sind die einzigen Daten,
die ich weitergegeben hab.
Keine Kommentare, keine Accounts,
E-Mail-Adressen, nichts in der Hinsicht
wurde weitergegeben, bevor jetzt wieder
irgendjemand einen auf Datenschützer macht.
Wer macht 2019 noch auf Datenschützer?
Asus ROG?
Zum Thema ROG, ne?
Ich hab seit 4 Jahren oder so
so ne Asus ROG-Kappe.
Mal auf der,
von wann war das?
Von irgendeiner ESL-Veranstaltung
in Köln war das, genau.
Und ich hab jetzt letztens Asus gefragt,
ob sie mir nicht einfach mal ne neue Kappe geben könnten,
weil die geht langsam kaputt.
Haben sie gesagt, machen sie.
Das ist jetzt irgendwie 2 Monate her, ich hab immer noch keine Kappe.
Was mach ich denn jetzt?
Ich krieg immer weniger Haare und wenn ich Sonnenbrand hab,
ist Asus dran schuld.
Oh!
Nice!
Huge Sellout!
Strix Flare Black Ops 4 Edition empfehlen.
Apropos Sellout!
Jetzt, wo der Aura
gerade Sellout macht.
Ich mach demnächst auch Sellout wahrscheinlich.
Äh, für
Tom Clancy's
Ghosts
Recon Breakpoint.
Hat mich heute nämlich jemand angeschrieben
per Mail, anscheinend haben die irgendwie so
nen Live-Ticker, wer wieder aktiv
wird auf YouTube oder so, keine Ahnung.
Ähm, da müssen wir uns übrigens gleich
nochmal ein Gameplay von angucken, was er dazu sagt.
Ich finde, das sieht, ähm, okay
aus, aber das war's dann auch, ja.
Ähm, genau,
Breakpoint,
da sind die gleichen, also mit denen hab ich schon mal
was gemacht, und das gibt
halt ordentlich, ordentlich Money.
Deswegen, für ordentlich Money mach ich auch
Sellout für alles mögliche.
Kein Ding.
Kein Problem. Viel angepasste Beleuchtung machen diese
Tastatur wirklich einzigartig.
Die Strix Flare gibt es alternativ
natürlich auch im gewohnten ROG-Design
und durch das austauschbare Logo-Badge
Für Money auch Facecams, für Money
mach ich alles, aber es kommt halt immer auf die Bezahlung an,
ja.
Euren individuellen Wünschen anpassen.
Euer Peripherie-Kit könnt ihr dann mit dem ROG
Sheath Mousepad perfekt abrunden.
Bevor wir loslegen, ich werd auch gleich zu der Umfrage
an sich nochmal ein bisschen was sagen, schauen wir uns
erstmal kurz den Marktanteil an, um so ein bisschen
eine Übersicht über meine Umfrage
und die Ergebnisse zu bekommen.
Wir hatten insgesamt 2.726
Einträge. Moment, um was geht's?
Das war Sonntagabend.
Mittlerweile sind es über 3.000.
Die hat, ach jetzt kapier ich's,
eine Umfrage gemacht.
Auf wie viel die Ryzen-CPUs boosten
bei den Leuten?
An einem gewissen Punkt einfach quasi
die Umfrage beenden, beziehungsweise mir die Daten ziehen
und mit diesen Daten auch arbeiten.
Und ich wollte auch ehrlich gesagt nicht zu viel
Zeit lassen, dass da zu viel Zeit
vergeht, weil das gibt natürlich auch
gewissen Herstellern, sag ich mal, die Möglichkeit
darauf zu reagieren. Das Ganze möchte ich
natürlich vermeiden, dass die Umfrage
so real und nachvollziehbar
wie möglich bleibt. Wenn wir uns das Ganze
anschauen, dann sehen wir, der größte
Marktanteil ist aktuell mit 40%
der 3.700X. Ja gut, das wurde aber nicht.
Der Erfolg von 3.900X mit 26%.
Wir haben uns ja mal aus Spaß
einen Rechner zusammengestellt im Stream,
wo ich mir überlegt habe, ob ich mir nicht
einen Ryzen kaufe, einen Ryzen-Streaming-Rechner
kaufen soll. Allerdings
habe ich dann
gesagt, das ist eigentlich total bescheuert, wozu, ne?
Und ich glaube, da haben wir auch den genommen,
den 3.700X.
Oder den 3.800X.
Und wir haben den 3.700X,
glaube ich, damals auch
eingeplant, weil
ordentlich Kern, ordentlich
Takt und alles andere
da drüber und da drunter war preis-leistungsmäßig
nicht viel besser, schlechter, als
dass ich das gelohnt hätte.
Dem 3.600X gefolgt mit 21%,
danach kommt mit 7% der
3.600X und nur mit
6% der 3.800X.
Das war eigentlich abzusehen,
weil natürlich der 3.800X
jetzt nicht wirklich die CPU ist, die Sinn macht.
Also kann ich auch nicht empfehlen.
Dementsprechend war das ungefähr abzusehen.
Aber es ist sehr cool, dass wir zumindest mal
3.700X, 3.900X und 3.600X
haben wir extrem viele Ergebnisse.
Beim 3.700X über 1.000.
Dementsprechend sind die Ergebnisse
dann auch gut nachzuvollziehen.
Und auch sehr glaubwürdig.
Ich habe auch sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht,
einfach nur die ganzen Kommentare zu lesen und
das auch abzugleichen, weil viele waren sich zum Beispiel
nicht sicher, welche AGESA-Version sie verwenden,
haben dann aber in die Kommentare zum Beispiel hingeschrieben,
BIOS-Version, F4 oder was auch immer.
Dann habe ich auf der Hersteller-Website extra nochmal
nachgeschaut, was das für eine Version war, habe das dann
abgeglichen. Also es waren sehr viele Ergebnisse,
wo ich dann nochmal was quasi nacheditiert
habe. Ihr habt viele Screenshots angehängt.
Ich habe mir alles angeschaut.
War sehr, sehr viel Arbeit. Aber
ich wollte natürlich auch sicher sein, dass die Ergebnisse
so zuverlässig wie möglich sind.
Einige Kommentare, die drin waren, auf
die möchte ich mal kurz eingehen.
Zum Beispiel hatte ich jemanden dabei, der
gesagt hat, okay, ich hatte eine krasse
Wasserkühlung mit einem Chiller und da lief...
Habt ihr was dagegen, wenn wir die Comments überspringen
und uns die Ergebnisse angucken?
1,25 Speed, nee.
Das hört sich beknackt an.
Überskippen, okay.
...individuell verwendeten Mainboard.
Ganz so einfach ist die Sache leider nicht.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen, weil es ist nicht unbedingt
Mainboard-abhängig. Es ist auch
AGESA-abhängig und dann
dazu auch noch SMU-abhängig.
Also SMU ist ja sowas wie zum Beispiel
die Management Engine bei Intel. Das ist nochmal
so ein Teil, der auch mit geflasht wird,
wenn man zum Beispiel das BIOS flasht.
Und es kommt tatsächlich eben auch vor...
Offizieller Backdoor.
...dass man die gleiche AGESA-Version hat, aber
unterschiedliche SMU-Versionen.
Und das Ganze macht es einfach unfassbar kompliziert,
aber dann ist das Ergebnis, dass man auch
mit einem Mainboard, das zum Beispiel
bei Hardware unboxt, das
X570 AOS Extreme
sehr gut boostet,
hier in der Umfrage trotzdem
viele Probleme hat. Und das schauen wir uns dann
gleich auch noch an. Und da muss man sich
natürlich fragen, wer ist hier
der Schuldige? Und ich muss sagen, es sind sowohl
Mainboard-Hersteller als auch AMD
definitiv schuld an diesem ganzen Chaos.
Erstmal haben wir das Problem, dass
AMD kein Referenzboard hat.
Das bedeutet, AMD hat kein
Board, wo wir sagen können, okay,
wir gehen in den Laden, kaufen, und da wissen wir definitiv,
jedes System funktioniert darauf.
Es ist ja so, dass AMD
quasi Hilfe gibt den Board-Herstellern,
aber die Board-Hersteller letztendlich alleine
dastehen, wenn sie ihr Board designen.
Und so sagen es zum Beispiel auch die Board-Hersteller
zu mir, die sagen dann, okay, wir kriegen
zwar Feedback und Hilfe von AMD, aber
oft weiß AMD auch nicht so genau,
was da los ist. Und dann kommt zum Beispiel
AMD und schaut sich das bei Asus
zum Beispiel an und lässt sich selbst Workshops
geben, um über die eigene CPU zu lernen.
Und es ist einfach ein unfassbares Chaos,
was da hinter den Kulissen herrscht. Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Und da muss man einfach sagen, sowohl
die Mainboard-Hersteller als auch
AMD sind da einfach, ich sag mal,
schuld. AMD müsste da besser
kontrollieren, müsste gegebenenfalls ein Referenzboard
entwickeln, auf dem sie sagen, okay,
in diesem Zustand läuft alles.
Daran könnt ihr euch orientieren. Das kriegt wahrscheinlich
AMD nicht hin, was zu
entwickeln, wo alles drauf läuft.
Und auf Basis davon könnt ihr euer
eigenes Board entwickeln. Aber
das ist nicht der Fall. Sondern wir haben kein
Board, auf dem wir sicher sagen können, hier funktioniert es
oder hier funktioniert es nicht. Also die Sache
ist leider nicht ganz so einfach. Kommen wir jetzt endlich
zur Auswertung. Natürlich wollte ich vorher
diese Sachen klarstellen. Das ist einfach wichtig,
bevor wir über die Ergebnisse reden, dass
ihr wisst, wie meine Ansichten dazu sind,
dass es natürlich auch kritisch zu betrachten ist,
so eine ganze öffentliche Umfrage.
Wir kommen jetzt zum Ryzen 5 3060.
Wir hatten 568 Ergebnisse,
die ich als korrekt erachtet habe.
Bei jeder CPU habe ich so 3, 4, 5
Ergebnisse aussortieren müssen, die halt irgendwelche
Troll-Ergebnisse waren. Aber ja, da reden wir von 0,5
bis 1%. Das hat natürlich keinen großen Einfluss.
Und jetzt seht ihr
vor euch ein Histogramm.
Das bedeutet, wir haben hier eine
Häufigkeitsverteilung. Ihr seht in der Mitte
diese einzelnen Balken. Und die einzelnen
Balken beschreiben einfach, wie
häufig ein gewisser Takt erreicht
wurde. Und hier reden wir natürlich
über den maximal erreichten
Single-Core-Takt
im Cinebench F15. Also zum Beispiel
die größte Säule
ist bei 4200 MHz.
Wir haben 245 Ergebnisse,
die den korrekten Boost
von 4,2 GHz
erreicht haben. Also nur, dass ich
das jetzt verstehe.
Nur, dass ich das jetzt verstehe.
Also sprich, oder ihr könnt aber
sagen, wie ihr das verstanden habt. Sprich, ich habe eine Umfrage
gemacht, wo die Leute quasi sagen konnten,
was ihren Ryzen 5
2600, was der für
einen Boost-Takt erreicht.
Das heißt, es haben
31 Leute quasi
Submitted, dass der
4025 MHz erreicht.
Und es haben 245
Submitted, dass der 4200
erreicht.
Und ist jetzt 4200
ist das jetzt der
offizielle, gibt es da
überhaupt einen offiziellen Boost irgendwie?
Oder sagen die einfach nur
ähm
wir boosten so viel wie geht.
Okay, 4200 ist offiziell.
Aha.
Na gut, wenn 4200 offiziell ist,
ist es aber schon ganz schön kacke,
dass sagen wir mal die Hälfte
die Hälfte unter dem offiziellen
Boost ist, oder? Das wäre
ganz schön fail. Der Toaster
hat Twitch Prime subscribt.
Nice, dankeschön.
Das ist natürlich sehr
schön zu sehen. Und wenn wir jetzt einfach mal nach links und
rechts schauen, wir sehen, es gibt nur ganz wenige
CPUs, die über dem Boost liegen. Also zum Beispiel
11 Ergebnisse bei 4200
25 und so weiter. Nach unten
natürlich das gleiche Thema. Wir haben auch
einige Ergebnisse, die deutlich drunter liegen.
4100, 4125
MHz. Und jetzt seht ihr
links und rechts zwei Striche. Also
minus 2 Sigma und
plus 2 Sigma. Wenn man
so ein Histogramm hier erstellt,
das ist eigentlich extrem wichtig. Das macht man
vor allem auch, wenn man jetzt Produkte irgendwie
herstellt. Also bei einer CNC
Fräse zum Beispiel. Oh, das ist
wirklich für High IQ
Leute geil. Man kann dann
zum Beispiel sehr gut sehen, wie
ist so die Zuverlässigkeit bei
der Produktion. Und man kann auch
Messfehler sehr gut ausgrenzen.
Und man sagt bei so einer Analyse eigentlich,
wenn man so ein Histogramm erstellt,
dass alles außerhalb von
minus 2 und plus 2 Sigma
als Fehler anzusehen ist.
Und in unserem Fall seht ihr
zum Beispiel, wir haben da 4025
ganz links.
Und jetzt seht ihr links oben
beim Diagramm die
berechneten Werte. Ihr seht, minus 2
Sigma ist bei 4015
Megahertz und plus 2 Sigma ist bei
4300 Megahertz. Also alles, was über
4300 liegt.
Bei 4025 nicht bei
4015, oder?
Oder ist es? Wird hier als
Messfehler deklariert. Das sind Ergebnisse, die wir
nicht betrachten. Und alles,
was unter 4015 Megahertz liegt,
wird in dieser Analyse auch
nicht betrachtet. Das bedeutet, wenn wir
minus 2 und plus 2 Sigma betrachten, dann sind
542 der 568
Ergebnisse innerhalb dieses Bereiches.
Das entspricht ungefähr
95% und die anderen
5%, also minus 2,5%
plus 2,5%,
die werden quasi als Messfehler
aussortiert. Das ist einfach
unfassbar wichtig. Ansonsten ruiniert
man sich diese Ergebnisse, weil man eben
sagen kann, wenn hier einer bei 4400
Megahertz liegt. Also das heißt im Endeffekt,
dass man die gar zu
extrem Bullshit Ergebnisse aussortiert.
Wenn jetzt irgendwie einer nur eine
Boosttakt von, keine Ahnung,
2 Megahertz hat oder so, wird das
sonst das ganze Bild versauen, wenn ich das
richtig verstehe.
Deswegen schneidet er das einfach ab.
Sagt er, was quasi
so weiter als so abweicht,
fliegt weg und weiter als so abweicht,
fliegt weg.
Dann ist das einfach extrem unwahrscheinlich
und größtenteils dann entweder
ein falscher Eintrag oder ein Messfehler.
Deswegen werden solche Werte
dann nicht betrachtet.
Wenn wir jetzt das Ergebnis betrachten, dann liegen 270
der 542
CPUs innerhalb
der Spezifikation. Das heißt, die haben
den Boost erreicht von den
beworbenen 4,2 Gigahertz
oder lagen drüber. Alles andere,
also 50%, die Hälfte
der CPUs, hat den angegebenen
Boost nicht erreicht.
Habe ich doch gerade gesagt,
also da habe ich das richtig interpretiert.
Das ist doch Fail, oder?
Also ich meine, wenn AMD sagt, 4200
ist Boost
und die CPU kriegt das nicht gebacken, dann
sollen sie nicht 4200
draufschreiben.
Wir reden hier ja von dem maximalen
Single-Core-Takt,
den wir irgendwann mal
während dem Benchmark gesehen haben. Und wenn ihr selber mitgemacht
habt, dann wisst ihr, diese 4,2
Gigahertz, die wahrscheinlich mal erreicht wurden,
die liegen dann nicht durchgehend an, sondern die
CPU geht dann wieder runter auf
4100, 4125.
Das heißt, wir haben hier ja nur den oberen
krassen Fall betrachtet. In der Realität
kann man von diesen Ergebnissen eigentlich nochmal 50
bis 75 Megahertz abziehen.
Das heißt, das Ganze ist eigentlich noch ein bisschen kritischer, als das wir sehen.
Aber beim Ryzen 5 3600
sieht es nicht so schlimm aus. Da liegen immerhin
50 Prozent, also jede zweite CPU
erreicht den Boost-Takt. Das ist schon mal ein gutes Ergebnis.
Jetzt wird das Ganze noch ein bisschen
interessanter, denn jetzt schauen wir uns den
3600X an. Also jetzt wird es ja immer anspruchsvoller.
Die CPUs, die wir jetzt betrachten, haben alle
immer mehr, immer mehr Takt angegeben.
Dementsprechend wird es auch immer, immer schwieriger
für die CPU, diesen Takt natürlich zu erreichen.
3600X, 190
Ergebnisse plus Sigma bei
4497, minus 2 Sigma bei
4143.
Das heißt, wir hatten ein paar Ergebnisse, die links und rechts
davon waren, die wir natürlich nicht
betrachten. Wir haben 180
von 190 Ergebnissen innerhalb
der minus und plus 2 Sigma.
Das heißt, nur 10 Ergebnisse werden quasi
als Messtoleranz
angesehen. Wenn wir uns jetzt aber anschauen, wie
viele CPUs tatsächlich den maximalen Boost
erreicht haben, dann sind das gerade mal
17 aus 180.
Nur, dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Also AMD
sagt zum Beispiel,
maximal Boost ist
4200.
Allerdings ist
maximal Boost, wie ist das?
Das ist nicht irgendwie garantiert
so nach dem Motto, hey, wenn nur ein Kern
ausgelastet ist, dann kriegst
du auch 4200, sondern das
ist, wenn noch genug Spielraum,
das ist doch nur, wenn
noch genug, wie sagt man da, so
Thermal,
also, wie heißt denn das
auf Deutsch?
Verlust, irgendwie.
Im Prinzip, wenn noch genug Spielraum
bei der Temperatur ist.
Oder?
Also mal angenommen,
ich passiv kühle das Ding jetzt,
also mal angenommen, ich passiv kühle
das Ding jetzt, dann müsste ich
mich auch nicht wundern, wenn der gar nicht boostet.
Das ist einfach Turbo-Taste am
PC drücken.
Das sind nur 9,4%
der CPUs haben die 4,4
GHz Boost kurz gesehen oder
waren drüber. Drüber waren nur 3,
einer war bei 4425,
einer war bei 4450.
Alle anderen
glatte 90% der CPUs
haben den Boost nicht erreicht.
Kommen wir jetzt zum 3700X,
wahrscheinlich das wichtigste Ergebnis,
weil wir haben hier über 1000 Ergebnisse,
1087 insgesamt,
minus 2 Sigma bei
4211 MHz plus
2 Sigma bei 4477.
Der größte Teil runter.
Auf der linken Seite, also unterhalb 2 Sigma,
da haben wir viele einzelne Ergebnisse,
z.B. 2 bei 4050,
3 bei 4075,
da kann man sich sicher sein, dass irgendwas nicht passt.
Wenn die CPU nur so hoch boostet,
dann ist es entweder ein BIOS-Bug oder
irgendwas anderes ist mit der Konfiguration
vom Setup nicht richtig, deswegen ist es
auch korrekt, dass diese Ergebnisse
natürlich quasi gestrichen werden
durch die Gauss-Verteilung.
Wir haben dennoch insgesamt 1036
aus 1087 Ergebnissen.
Wie wir als gültig betrachten.
Und wenn wir jetzt den Boost anschauen,
dann haben wir 153 aus
1039 CPUs,
die mindestens
den...
Ach so, KingWall, jetzt kapier ich das.
Es geht gar nicht so sehr um die technische
Seite, die scheiße wär, sondern
dass quasi AMD draufschreibt
und
die Leute dann halt, sagen wir mal,
den Standardkühler draufmachen und sich beschweren,
dass es nicht 4400 ist.
Oder das Ding zurückschicken oder so.
Was natürlich für Caseking oder woran arbeitet
ziemlich suckt, wenn die Leute laufend
CPUs zurückschicken.
Also im Prinzip müsste AMD sagen,
maximal Boost 4400,
nur wenn
ihr da, keine Ahnung,
Stickstoff draufmacht.
So nach dem Motto.
Boost erreicht haben von
4,4 GHz. Wir haben
19 CPUs, die drüber waren, also
4,425 zum Beispiel, 4,45
und dann haben wir, wenn wir es noch
ein bisschen stretchen, den Plus 2 Sigma hätten
vielleicht nochmal 5 dazu. Aber das
macht den Braten nicht fett. Dann hätten wir 158
aus 1039. Also
es ist immer noch, ja, eine sehr
kleine Anzahl. Wir haben...
Das ist kein Hitzeproblem. Das heißt, die Dinger
schaffen einfach, egal wie gut gekühlt, den Boost
nicht, obwohl es AMD draufschreibt, oder wie?
Ja, das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Das ist natürlich begnackt.
Ähm...
DrPwnz fragt, du hast mal
irgendwie zu i3 Window Manager oder
so Linux-mäßig geswitcht. Wie heißt das Programm?
i3 Window Manager?
i3 WM heißt
das. Oder was meinst du?
Wir haben
insgesamt 85% der CPUs, die den
Boost nicht erreichen. Und jetzt sagt ihr vielleicht, okay,
aber 415 Ergebnisse
erreichen 4,375
und kann man da nicht einfach aufrunden?
Nein, kann man nicht. Definitiv nicht.
Weil es ja auch oft so ist, dass
die CPUs einen Boost, äh,
weil es ja oft auch so ist, dass die CPUs einen
BCLK von 99,8 MHz
verwenden. Achso, ja, vor allem ja.
Das heißt, ihr habt da
4366 MHz in der Realität
und wir haben hier nur
den maximalen Single-Core-Boost.
Das heißt, alle, die jetzt zum Beispiel
4,375 angegeben haben
und das als Maximum erreicht haben,
haben während dem Benchmark meistens
trotzdem nur 4,3, vielleicht
4,325. Das heißt, man kann
hier nicht einfach aufrunden.
So einfach ist das Problem nicht
zu lösen. Kommen wir zum
3800X. In diese CPU hatte ich eigentlich
mit die meiste Hoffnung, weil der 3800X
laut AMD ja quasi
ein Hörgebinder 3700X ist.
Also der müsste eigentlich den Boost ja
eher erreichen. Und weil es eben
kein 12-Canner ist, sondern nur ein 8-Canner,
ist die Leistungsaufnahme nicht ganz
so hoch. Das heißt, bei dieser CPU hatte ich
quasi die größte Hoffnung, dass der Boost
erreicht wird. Wir hatten 159
Ergebnisse. 9 Ergebnisse
sind durch Minus 2 und Plus 2
Sigma rausgefallen und wenn
wir uns jetzt anschauen, wie viele im Boost
liegen, dann waren das 26,7%,
die bei 4,5 oder drüber
lagen. Wir hatten relativ viele, die
dann 4,5 oder 5 und 4,55
hatten. Also das war eigentlich
ganz gut zu sehen. Und dann sehen wir auch
48 Ergebnisse bei
4,475, also wieder das gleiche Spiel,
wo der Boost quasi knapp verfehlt
wurde maximal, aber eben während
der Benchmark dann ja trotzdem der Boost
noch weiter abfällt. Aber auch hier
quasi drei Viertel der CPUs
hat den Boost
nicht erreicht. Kommen wir jetzt
zum 3900X
und aus meiner Sicht auch mit so die
wichtigste CPU, weil die ja auch so den krass
höchsten Boost hat in
der Werbung und natürlich
im Hinblick auf den kommenden 3950.
Wie ist der Stand mit der ASP-Seite?
Meinst du die Fiverr-Geschichte oder
meinst du den für SunTracker? Der nochmal 100
MHz mehr können soll,
stehe ich dem Ganzen natürlich relativ
kritisch gegenüber, sage ich mal, was
den beworbenen Boost betrifft. Fiverr sage ich gleich
was zu. Wir haben bei dem 3900X insgesamt
Ergebnisse. Minus 2 Sigma
bei 4238, plus 2
bei 4711. Wir
hatten darüber fast kein
Ergebnis, was rausgefiltert wurde,
aber darunter einige, also ihr
seht, wir hatten bei 425,
bei 4100, da
kann man sich natürlich sicher sein, dass da bei dem
3900X auf jeden Fall was nicht stimmen kann.
685 der
722 Ergebnisse
waren innerhalb der Minus und Plus
2 Sigma und wurden quasi als
Kulti-Gewertung in der Wertung.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal anschauen, wie viele
CPUs den Boost tatsächlich schaffen, dann ist
das wirklich vernichtend. Wir haben
hier glatte 5%,
38 aus 674
CPUs haben den Boost
erreicht. Wenn man das mal anschaut, wir hatten
13 bei 4600 und dann
ein paar drüber, 4625,
4650, muss man ganz klar sagen,
95%
der CPUs
erreichen den Boost nicht.
Und das
muss man sich erstmal auf der Zunge jetzt ergehen lassen.
Das heißt, eigentlich keine.
Also 95% der CPUs
erreichen den Boost-Takt nicht.
Das ist eine krasse Nummer.
Das ist deutlich schlimmer, als ich dachte
und damit kann ich auch ganz klar bestätigen, dass es
nicht ein Problem ist, was nur bei mir existiert,
wie es am Anfang hieß.
Bei meinem allerersten Video, das sich ja veröffentlicht hat,
als die Ryzen CPUs auf den Markt gekommen
sind, da habe ich ja das Thema quasi als erstes
angesprochen. Da kam Feedback
von vielen anderen, die gesagt haben,
du bist der einzige, der darüber berichtet,
kein anderer Reviewer hat es.
Das kann ich auch nicht irgendwie erzwingen
oder so. Also wenn die CPU
nicht will, dann will sie nicht.
Also ich kann jetzt nicht irgendwie
sagen, so nach dem Motto,
ich mach jetzt irgendwie, ich sag jetzt mal doof,
Multiplikator höher, irgendwas höher,
Multi-Core-Enhancement irgendwas höher
und sag, ey CPU, mach diesen Takt
scheiß drauf, ob du abkackst.
Also im Prinzip, wenn AMD
das intern irgendwie so eingestellt hat,
dass das nicht geht, dann geht das nicht.
...
am Start behauptet oder gesagt,
bei dir muss irgendwas falsch gelaufen sein.
So war so der Tonus. Nicht nur von mir,
also nicht nur von anderen Reviewern, sondern auch von AMD
selbst, sag ich mal. Und das hat mir natürlich
auch selber zu denken gegeben, hab dann quasi
daran gezweifelt, geschaut, hab ich irgendwas falsch gemacht?
Ich würde sagen, definitiv nicht.
Wir haben hier definitiv
ein Problem. Und jetzt, wo wir die 3900X
Ergebnisse kennen und ihr wahrscheinlich sagen
werdet, aber das hängt alles vom Mainboard ab,
schauen wir jetzt mal eine
Mainboard-spezifische Analyse an und da schauen
wir jetzt den 3900X an
auf dem X570
Aorus Xtreme. Das war das Board, was bei
Hardware Unboxed am besten abgeschlossen hat,
abgeschnitten hat und wo er gesagt hat,
okay, hier erreicht
eigentlich jeder Kern den Boost beim
3800X. Wir haben jetzt hier den
3900X, weil ich hier die meisten Ergebnisse mit diesem Board
hatte. Ja, da muss man
ganz klar sagen, wenn wir uns das anschauen, wir
haben 5 CPUs aus
27,
die das mit diesem Board schaffen. Das heißt,
22 CPUs haben es auch hier nicht geschafft. Also ihr seht,
es liegt teilweise deutlich drunter.
Man kann hier nicht so einfach sagen, dass wenn man
das Board kauft, dass plötzlich alle Probleme gelöst
sind. Das gleiche
nochmal nur als zweites Board, weil
ich damit auch mit so die meisten Ergebnisse hatte,
war das X570 Aorus Elite. 37
Ergebnisse, paar lagen drunter, wurden
quasi aussortiert durch das
Minus 2 Sigma. Wir sehen 2
CPUs aus 37
erreichen den Boost
und 35 liegen drunter.
Weiß nicht.
Was soll ich dazu sagen?
Es ist ein sehr komplexes Thema.
Piss dich AMD. Ich glaube, da werden wir noch lange dran zu
knabbern haben. AMD auch. Aber trotzdem sind die
Ryzen CPUs nicht übel. Ich hoffe, ich habe das Video jetzt nicht zu lange gestretched,
weil, ja, ich wollte natürlich
so viele Daten wie möglich präsentieren. Ich habe nicht
alles präsentieren können.
Wir haben natürlich auch noch viele
Analysen, die wir rausziehen können, was Mainboard
betrifft, was AG-Verweisung betrifft und so weiter.
Wäre für dieses Video viel zu viel.
Um es nochmal kurz zusammenzufassen.
Aktuell beste CPU,
was die beworbene Boost-Frequenz
betrifft, ist der 3600.
4,2 GHz Boost ist eben auch nicht
so schwer zu erreichen. Wenn wir alles
andere betrachten, gerade den
3900X mit
95%, die den Boost nicht schaffen,
dann ist das wirklich
viel, viel, viel schlimmer,
als ich dachte. Ich dachte, so
vielleicht 50% schaffen das, aber 95%
nicht, sehe ich
tatsächlich als großes Problem an und ich glaube
auch nicht, dass es so einfach zu lösen ist. Weil ich habe
mit allen Mainboard-Herstellern gesprochen, über die
Ergebnisse. Mit allen habe ich telefoniert.
Alle haben mir gegenüber
bestätigt, dass es bei denen intern auch so
aussieht und sie keine Lösung haben, um
dieses Problem zu lösen. Haben auch mit AMD
gesprochen und AMD aktuell quasi
auch keine Lösung dafür
besitzt. Das Ganze wird übrigens von einem
Statement von Charmino, der bei Asus arbeitet,
untermauert. Link ich euch unten
rein, könnt ihr euch auch mal durchlesen.
Ich glaube, dass die CPUs in
der Fertigung einfach nicht so
gut sind, wie das,
was beworben wird. Was
ich dann natürlich auch direkt wieder sagen muss,
die CPUs sind extrem gut. Versteht mich
nicht wieder falsch. Der Ryzen
3000 ist nach wie vor eine unfassbar
gute CPU und ich rate jedem dazu,
wenn ihr euch ein neues Setup holt,
schaut euch die CPU an
und bevor ihr z.B. einen 9900K
kauft, gerade wenn ihr Creator seid,
überlegt euch das und kauft euch vielleicht doch
einen Ryzen. Das sage ich ganz deutlich, weil
die CPUs extrem gut sind. Gerade der 3600,
was Preis-Performance angeht,
eine unschlagbare CPU.
Ich rate euch dazu, kauft die CPUs.
Aber seid nicht enttäuscht, wenn der
Boost am Ende nicht funktioniert.
Man kommt nicht zu mir an bei Caseking und sagt, ich möchte
die CPU zurückgeben, weil der Boost nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe es euch gesagt. Das soll ich nur
loswerden. Jetzt müssen wir eigentlich die E-Mail an Caseking
schreiben. Ich möchte die CPU
zurückgeben.
Lasst mich gerne wissen in den Kommentaren, was ihr davon haltet.
Wenn ihr spezifische Sachen
haben wollt, gerne unten rein. Ich schaue
mir das gerne an. Ich nehme mir die Zeit dazu,
noch mehr Analysen zu machen. Wir machen gerne Follow-Up
Videos zu diesem Thema.
Aber ich glaube, dass die CPUs,
diesen Boost niemals schaffen werden,
weil sie einfach in der Fertigung nicht
so gut sind, wie AMD
es gerne hätte für den Boost, was auch nie nötig
war. Man hätte einfach den Boost nie so
bewerben dürfen und sollen. Einfach nur,
um quasi, ich weiß nicht, Investoren zufrieden
zu stellen oder weil man sagt, vielleicht
kaufen die mehr, wenn ich 4,6 Gigahertz draufschreibe.
Die hätten das einfach so machen sollen.
Da hätten sie mal was von
deutschen Internet-Providern lernen
können. Die sollten einfach nicht
draufschreiben, Boost-Takt 4400.
Die sollten das einfach machen, mit
DSL-Anbieter sollen draufschreiben,
Boost-Takt bis zu 4400.
Alles wäre gut gewesen.
CPUs sind so gut.
Man hätte sich das Leben ohne die schwer machen müssen.
So, reicht jetzt aber.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Ciao.
Also ich muss echt sagen,
der Auer, also der Bauer,
das ist ein wirklich, der macht immer sehr
nice Videos. Die sind auch immer so,
wie sagt man, so fundiert irgendwie.
So durchdacht.
Also ich gucke
die Videos wirklich gerne.
Ich meine, mich interessiert nicht jedes Thema,
aber jedes Mal, wenn ich ein Video gucke,
sind die wirklich immer gut gemacht.
Ja, und auch vor allem, was mir an den Videos
gut gefällt ist, der stellt sich
halt hin und erzählt halt
um was es geht und macht
und macht nicht irgendwie
erstmal 30 Cuts, wo er
über den Bildschirm jumpt oder so.
Nö, der stellt sich hin, zeigt
das, erklärt das auch gut,
hat auch alle, wovon er erzählt. Also das ist wirklich
schon nice, ja.
Der Acht-Auer, genau.
Ich finde
die Videos gut.
Ah, ja, ja.
Also, Fiverr.
Jetzt kann ich was zu Fiverr erzählen.
Fiverr.
Also, ich habe,
ich habe elf,
ich habe elf, okay,
RIP Fiverr.
Ah, jetzt geht's, okay.
Also ich habe elf wahrscheinlich,
ich denke mal,
zum größten Teil indische,
alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben,
zum größten Teil indische
.NET Core, ASP.NET Programmierer
beauftragt, was zu
programmieren.
Und was die programmieren
sollten ist, so eine
kleine Twitch Chat,
so eine kleine Twitch Chat App.
Also haben wir selbst schon gebastelt
hier im Stream, ist nicht kompliziert.
Ungefähr 200 Zeilen Code inklusive
HTML. Wolltest du nicht
ein Video machen? Ey, gibt ja noch nix.
Gibt ja noch nix.
So, und
ich muss mich da jetzt erstmal einloggen,
dass ich es euch zeigen kann.
Und dazu muss ich euch mal ausschalten,
weil ich mich natürlich mit meiner privaten
E-Mail-Adresse registriert
habe, anstatt mich mal
mit meiner
Busyness E-Mail zu registrieren,
was aber auch Absicht gewesen ist,
denn ich will ja nicht, dass die mich irgendwie
enttarnen
oder so.
Okay, Moment Leute, ich logge mich mal kurz ein.
Video Capture
ausmachen.
Key Pass aufmachen auf
der anderen Seite.
Geht gleich weiter.
Fiverr.
Login.
Alter, das Login
funktioniert nicht.
Ey, das ist
jetzt, Fiverr, das ist jetzt nicht dein
Ernst. Fiverr ist übrigens die größte
Bullshit-Seite ever, weil
die alle furzlangen Captures
gelöst haben möchte von mir.
Das geht, das braucht
alle fünf Minuten kommt das auf Fiverr.
Wirklich, ohne
Scheiß, alle fünf Minuten.
Und dann geht das manchmal weg.
Und dann kommt das nächste Capture.
Und wenn das weggeht,
kommt das nächste Capture.
Und jetzt darf ich
Traffic Lights auswählen.
Das ist nicht U-Block.
Oh, ich hatte U-Block
gerade ausgeschaltet.
Ach, jetzt hat es noch nicht mal eingeloggt.
Alter, Fiverr.
Come on, bruh.
Vertippt. Richtig.
Ah, Fiverr.
Okay.
Sign in.
Ah.
Okay. Passwort.
Okay. Sign in.
Ah.
Never.
Okay.
Ich bin signed in.
Ich noob habe es jetzt zwar nicht
im anonymen Tab gemacht, aber
ist drauf geschissen.
Also, ich blende euch mal wieder ein.
Also, es fällt schon mal auf,
ich heiße Peter.
Wie man das aus dem
Inder-Scammer-Video kennt.
Ich muss mich
da mit irgendeinem Fake-Namen anmelden, ne?
Ich konnte mich ja wohl kaum so nennen wie mein YouTube-Channel
oder wie sonst was. Also, Peter ist am Start.
Ähm.
Und
jetzt passt mal auf die
Ausbeute, Leute.
Jetzt zeige ich... Also, ihr seht,
ich habe ganz schön viel beauftragt, ja?
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal die Orders an.
So.
Von elf Orders
haben sieben cancelled.
Ja, deswegen habe ich so viel Guthaben.
Weil die Leute gecancelt haben.
Die haben sich alle nicht getraut, das zu machen.
Sieben hatten keinen Bock.
Ey, Leute. Also, die cancelled kann ich euch
ja mal zeigen. Das ist echt lustig.
Also, wir fangen mal mit dem...
Ich weiß nicht.
Wir fangen jetzt einfach mal oben an.
Also.
Ja, genau.
Der hat überhaupt nicht gecheckt, was ich haben wollte, ne?
Also, ich habe ihm das hier geschrieben, ja?
Das ist wichtig, ne?
So, haben wir das nämlich auch gemacht.
So. Dann will ich, dass das Ganze ohne Twitch-Login
funktioniert. Dass man den Channel
und Usernamen konfigurieren kann.
Es ist nichts schwieriges.
Hört sich jetzt vielleicht kompliziert an. Ich kann euch gleich nochmal meine
Anwendungen zeigen. Das sind, wie gesagt, 200 Zeilen.
Dass die Chat-Messages
sollen gespeichert werden, da ich es neu starten kann.
Und ich hätte gerne einen Knopf, dass ich einzelne
Nachrichten löschen kann.
So, und jetzt kommt die Antwort von ihm. Die war auch
huge.
So, er hat hier geschrieben...
I have received your
order. Kindly send me link to...
of sample project
of detailed document
of your requirements.
What you want. So, und jetzt habe ich gesagt, okay,
ich habe dir doch geschrieben, was ich will.
Ähm...
Was...
Was willst du genau wissen?
Is this all you can explain?
Erklär mir doch was, was du nicht verstehst, ja?
Und dann hat er irgendwie sowas drauf
geschrieben. I could not
find out your... what
you... what this is
why I won't be able
to do your project. You can
move to any other seller. Thanks.
What?
Okay. Ja, und da habe ich halt
gesagt, ich habe cancelt, ja?
Ich will denen ja nicht das Leben schwer machen.
Ich will denen ja nicht das Leben wirklich
schwer machen. Ich habe immer, wenn die
gefragt haben, ja?
Immer, wenn die gefragt haben, cancel, habe ich immer
zugestimmt. Wie gesagt, ich will denen weder die Bewertung
versauen, noch will ich denen irgendwie das Leben
schwer machen oder die irgendwie abfacken oder so.
Ähm...
Der wollte nicht, ja?
Meine Beschreibung ist auch schlecht,
ja. Sagt richtig.
Die Beschreibung, ich habe mir im Nachhinein
nochmal drüber Gedanken gemacht, über die Beschreibung.
Die Beschreibung ist eigentlich ziemlich gut,
wie sie ist, weil
sie ist nicht hundertprozentig
klar. Ich hätte das
theoretisch hier drunter noch besser
beschreiben können, allerdings
wenn man, wenn man Programmierer
ist und quasi
es gehört ein bisschen mit
zur Aufgabe, dass man
dass man
ein Brain dafür hat,
so ungefähr zu erfassen, was die Leute haben wollen.
Also,
ich habe es den anderen, habe ich sogar noch
ein bisschen genauer erklärt.
Ähm...
Ja, hier 16,20 Euro.
Ey, der andere hat 4,70 Euro gehabt, ja?
Ähm, und
das dann mal,
dass man dann da nachfragt und das ist,
das ist okay, ja? Also, ich finde,
aus der Beschreibung erkennt man es eigentlich schon ganz gut.
Den anderen habe ich dann im Nachhinein nochmal
genauer erklärt, so nach dem Motto, ey,
ich will eine Anwendung haben, die
alle Chatnachrichten mitschneidet
aus einem gewissen Channel und einfach
filtert, ob mein Username drin vorkommt.
Was machst du gerade beruflich?
Mach mal Ausrufzeichen Beruf.
So, was hat man als nächstes gehabt?
Den hier hatten wir als nächstes. Der war schon für 20 Euro
am Start. Ach, der
hatte auch keinen Bock, ja? Obwohl er auf seiner
Seite schreibt, ähm,
I will do
ASP.NET MVC Core
2 Web, äh, was auch immer.
So, und das hier macht er alles.
Backend.NET Core, Frontend JavaScript,
also genau das,
genau, warum geht
Ausrufezeichen Beruf nicht? Ist der Nightbot kaputt?
Ach, ne, weil oben
drüber schon einer Ausrufezeichen Beruf gemacht hat.
So, und
der war auch geil. Sagt der mal, hello,
I'm not work on
Netbot Applications. Okay, cancel.
Hab ich gesagt, okay,
dann feel free to cancel.
Dann hat er halt gesagt, ja, okay, das würde seine
Ratings, ähm,
ja, okay, cancel ich halt. Okay.
Next.
Jetzt kommt als nächstes, kommt der Fullstack
Development on .NET.
Hi Max.
Sorry to tell you this, but
can you please cancel this order?
Das war das einzige, da hatte er
keinen Bock. Na gut, wer will auch für 11,43
Euro arbeiten, ja?
Wer will, wer hat da auch
Bock drauf, ja? Ich hätte auch
keinen Bock drauf, für 11,43 zu arbeiten.
Amit
hatte keinen Bock.
Ähm, obwohl er auch hier genau
geschrieben hat, wenn man sich das mal anguckt,
äh,
New Web App from scratch.
Der hat, der passt
also, ich hab mir ja wirklich Leute
rausgesucht, die, ähm,
die es auch so beschrieben haben,
dass sie das können und machen, was ich
haben will, ja? Sind das
alles, naja, es,
ich glaube, wenn
du einen Programmierer in Deutschland suchst,
der macht für 9,59 Euro nicht mal
seine IDE auf.
So, den haben wir als nächstes.
Develop any kind
of ASP.NET MVC or
Core Application, any kind, ja?
Hope you enjoying good
health.
Thanks for contacting, but I'm not
available, so kindly cancel your order.
Was ich witzig finde bei dem ist,
auf der Projektseite steht,
äh,
trust me, we are always
available for you.
Und das erste, was ich von ihm höre ist,
sorry, but I'm not available.
Huge.
Ähm,
aber gut, ich mein, der, der, das
war auch der billigste, 6,66 Euro.
Ey, Leute, die Sache
ist die, die Sache ist
ja die, 4,80 Euro,
Alter.
Ich mein,
I will develop a complete
web application in
this package. 4,80 Euro.
Ich
hab mir das ja nicht ausgedacht.
Ich hab ja schon, ich hab ja extra welche
gesucht, die das genau reingeschrieben haben.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich mir das aus...
Also, ich hab die ja nicht gezwungen dafür, das da reinzusetzen
oder so.
So, ähm,
next.
Bei den anderen, die anderen zwei
zeige ich euch heute noch nicht, da gucken wir uns erst die Ergebnisse an.
Und die anderen vier, bei den anderen vier hab ich noch Hoffnung,
ja. So, nächster.
I will do
bootstrap related work.
So, da hab ich ihm nochmal reingepastet, was ich haben will.
Hi, why are you
directly order?
Ey, die haben alle eigentlich ziemlich gute Bewertungen.
Da, da wollte ich erst zurückschreiben,
ja gut,
weil's auf deiner Seite steht.
Gut.
Cancel. Nächster.
Ähm, die letzten zwei waren
auch ganz cool.
Die wollten mehr Money haben.
Äh, der Steff.
Der Steff ist gut. Ich weiß nicht, wo der Steff herkommt,
aber der hat Ahnung.
Äh, was ist denn das?
Griechenland? Nee, wo ist das?
Wo kommt der, wo ist das?
Osteuropa, Mazedonien,
ja. Also, der hatte gefühlt,
gefühlt hatte der die meiste Ahnung.
Ja.
This is possible.
Da hab ich ihm gesagt, nee,
ich will das, ich will das Ganze nicht über die Twitch-IP haben,
aber, ähm,
ich habe irgendwo gehört,
dass, ähm,
der Twitch-Chat auch IRC hat.
Ähm, und ich habe
sogar mal ein paar Beispiele
gefunden, wie das IRC-Chat funktioniert,
aber, ähm, ich,
ich bin, ich bin nicht gut genug
dafür im Programmieren, um das selbst zu programmieren,
ja. Ähm,
when do you expect to finish?
No hurry, what you think? Well, I can start
tomorrow. Ähm,
fast hast
mehr Zeit. Ich habe ihm gesagt, ich, ich,
ich spende ihm sogar noch mal 11 Euro,
wenn er es in Zeiten, wenn er es rechtzeitig schafft, ja.
Und dann hat er gesagt, how much,
how much budget? Da hab ich schon gedacht,
Alter, jetzt will er mich, jetzt will er mich
gebeten. Habe ich einfach mal hingeschrieben, 50 Euro.
So, obwohl das Ding für 11 abgeschlossen
ist oder so, aber okay. Äh, 50 Euro.
Sorry, wartest du denn?
At least 700 Euro!
Hahaha.
Jetzt geht's ab.
You've got to make it.
You've got, you've got to make it.
Hahaha.
Also, einfach mal einen Gig reingesetzt
für 11,43
und dann
700 Euro haben wollen, das ist next level.
Aber ich habe nur darauf geantwortet, are you ready to
pay the price? No!
Hahaha. Ist das überhaupt
überlaubt über Fiverr? Keine Ahnung.
So,
der nächste, den hatten wir, einen haben wir noch,
einen haben wir noch. Der wollte auch, der wollte auch mehr Geld,
glaube ich.
Hello, thanks for order.
Okay, es wäre besser, wenn ich ihn vorher
kontaktiert hätte. Sorry, I can't
do this task. Für 20,96 Euro.
Was
fändest du ein angemessener Preis?
Pff, keine Ahnung. Also, wenn man das
ordentlich macht, wenn man das ordentlich
macht und ich sag mal, du brauchst so
1, 2,
sagen wir mal 3 Stunden, 3 Stunden
für, wenn du es ordentlich machst,
so, sag mal 150 Euro.
Ha?
Also, für 150 Euro
würde ich es mir überlegen.
Ja, Moment, du kannst es mit 100 Euro Stundenlohn ja nicht so
rechnen. Ich meine, ich muss ja erstmal auf die Seite gehen,
ich muss den Krams erstellen, ich muss Steuern
drauf bezahlen. Letztendlich, wenn du selbstständiger
Programmierer bist, ist es ein bisschen was anderes.
Ähm, da musst du dich schon ordentlich bezahlen
lassen. Also, für 150
Euro ist okay.
Kannst du kurz erklären,
was der Nuttyp bedeutet, also strikt offen?
Ich sag's, ich sag's jetzt nochmal.
Im, hier im Stream.
Ich hab's in den, ich hab's ganz oft in Kommentaren
geschrieben. Nuttyp.
Ich hab's ganz oft
in Kommentaren geschrieben. Und zwar,
ähm, haben wir mal
ein schönes Setting, schönes Bildchen für
Nuttyp.
Hier, da.
Dieses Wort
ist eine komplette Erfindung
der Konsolenhersteller. Es gibt
keinen Nuttyp.
Sowas existiert nicht.
Das einzige, was es gibt, ist
Ports weitergeleitet oder Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Alles andere
ist irgendwie ganz merkwürdige
Microsoft Sony Logik.
Es gibt in der Netzwerktechnik,
es gibt nichts, was sich Nuttyp
nennt. Entweder
leitest du die Ports weiter,
die gebraucht werden, oder du leitest
die Ports nicht weiter, die gebraucht werden. Fertig.
Also,
Nuttyp gibt es nicht.
Ich mein, ja, es gibt so Tabellen, wo
Leute dann gesagt haben, so nach dem Motto, ey,
äh, was verstehen denn die Konsolen
die Konsolenhersteller darunter?
Aber es gibt sowas in der
Netzwerktechnik nicht. Sowas wie Nuttyp.
Vielleicht meinen die da
Nein, was die meinen ist, du hast
Ports weitergeleitet oder Ports nicht
weitergeleitet. Das, das
meinen die damit. Nichts anderes.
Ich muss übrigens jetzt nochmal in die Settings
gehen. Da muss
ich in meine History
History
clear browser data
und
sagen clear.
Nuttyp
gibt es doch auch bei COD auf dem PC.
Okay, ich korrigiere, es war keine reine
Erfindung der Konsolenhersteller.
Es war eine Erfindung von Konsolen
Gameherstellern und Konsolenherstellern.
Wie sieht es mit den Active by Fiverr
aus?
Achso, was hat das Ganze jetzt mit Linux Mint zu tun?
Noch absolut gar nichts. Noch null.
Eigentlich hatte ich vor,
mir die neue Linux-Mint-Variante anzugucken,
die rausgekommen ist.
Cleaner Desktop ist nice, oder?
Ja, eigentlich, eigentlich.
Eigentlich sah der Desktop immer so aus.
Sort.
Wie sortet man hier nochmal?
Sieht doch schon gar nicht mehr so wild aus.
Also was die damit halt einfach meinen,
du hast deine Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Wenn du Ports weiterleiten
willst, gehst du auf deinen Router, suchst dir raus,
was das Spiel für Ports braucht und leitest die weiter.
Fertig.
Wie gesagt, das mit offen und geschlossen
ist
Bullshit der Spieleentwickler. So was
gibt es nicht. So, was
wollen wir eigentlich ausprobieren?
Also,
LMDE
Debian Edition
Was ist denn das
Neue? Das Neue war glaube ich Tina, ne?
Ja.
Tina, die haben immer Grillnamen.
Ja, 6. August.
Tina wollen wir haben.
Und Hannah Montana an die Linux-Maus
nächstes Mal. Oder vielleicht nachher noch.
Also wenn ihr Probleme habt, dass
irgendwas von wegen NAT-Typ drinsteht, ganz einfach.
Ihr googelt einfach,
welche Ports
ihr für das jeweilige Spiel oder für die
jeweilige Konsole, meinetwegen, weiterleiten müsst.
Tragt es in euren Router ein und gut ist.
Max, eines
deiner letzten Videos hat mich voll geil auf
BFPC3 gemacht. Ich hoffe das bald...
Oh ja, hoffe ich auch.
Und ich würde den PC
nicht auf Exposed Host stellen. Auf keinen Fall.
Nutzt du eigentlich Firefox?
Klar. Ich benutze fast alle Browser.
Außer
Opera Gaming Edition.
Oder wie dieses Ding heißt.
Das verwende ich nicht.
Okay, was interessiert uns denn am neuen
Linux Mint? Cinnamon Edition?
Featuring Cinnamon?
Mate? XFCE?
LMDE?
Was für einen Desktop wollen wir
mal ausprobieren?
Wir können doch alle 3 ausprobieren.
Also, Mate ist ein
Gnome 2 Fork.
XFCE ist was eigenes.
Auch auf GTK-Ambassung. Cinnamon ist glaube ich
eine Gnome 3 Geschichte.
Ich glaube Cinnamon
ist Standard.
Okay, 64bit.
Download.
Wir downloaden uns die Tina jetzt.
Gibt es, haben die auch ein
German Mirror? Ja, FHA.
Die sind immer schnell.
Das flutscht.
Mal an hier.
12 MBit die Sekunde, kann ich mit leben.
Hey Max, ich bin glücklicher Besitzer
einer DS Lite Leitung.
Debated.
Aber die Frage kommt tatsächlich öfters.
Mit DS Lite,
um es jetzt nochmal ausdrücklich zu sagen,
mit DS Lite hat man gelitten,
wenn man daheim was
laufen lassen will. Funktioniert nicht.
Es sei denn, alle connecten
sich bei IPv6, was aber die wenigsten
machen werden. Hast du eine
250er Leitung? Nee, aktuell habe ich
nur eine 100 Down,
5 Up, aber demnächst
habe ich wie gesagt 40 Up, 400 Down.
Dünn DNS?
Dünn DNS bringt dir überhaupt nichts bei
DS Lite, gar nichts.
Um nicht zu sagen 0.
Weil Dünn DNS sorgt ja nicht dafür, dass
die Leute auf einmal
durch das NAT durchkommen vom Provider.
Hamachi, Hamachi funktioniert
ja.
VPN-Geschichten funktionieren auch.
Lycans, ja.
Ich meine Zuschauer ja auch.
Übrigens,
Prime.
Wollte ich nur mal anmerken.
Primer im Chat.
Der huge
Sellout, der kommt nachher.
SSH-Tunnel dürfte auch gehen.
Ja, der SSH-Tunnel geht auch.
Alle möglichen Sachen, die es irgendwie schaffen,
von außen, äh, von innen nach außen
eine Verbindung aufzubauen, wo man dann von außen
nach innen kann, funktionieren.
Ist DS Lite das, was
Unity Media macht? Genau. Also nur um das
nochmal kurz zu erklären, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
DS Lite. Mal gucken, ob es da schöne Bilder dazu gibt.
Da muss ich den nicht selbst malen.
Was für einen Prozessor würdest du ja
empfehlen für aktuelle Games?
AMD oder Intel?
Also aktuell würde ich mir einen Ryzen kaufen.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich mir entweder
einen
3700X war das, glaube ich, oder
einen 3800X würde ich mir kaufen.
Wir hatten letztens ja mal im Stream sowas zusammengestellt.
Okay,
DS Lite ist nicht so eine gute Idee zu suchen.
Dual Stack Lite.
Ja, das ist doch
ein ganz schönes Bild.
Ja, das ist, das ist ein schönes Bild.
Also, was uns das Ganze
in diesem Bild hier sagen möchte, ist folgendes.
Ist da vielleicht noch ein schöneres
Bild für... was da, ha?
Das ist zu übertrieben. Das Bild ist aber ganz
gut hier. Also, was
DS Lite, beziehungsweise DS Lite
mit, muss man dazu sagen, noch Carrier Crate
nut, nennt sich das Ganze, ja?
Ähm...
Was sie machen ist folgendes, oder warum
machen die das überhaupt? Unity Media hat
zu wenige IPv4-Adressen, zumindest in der Vergangenheit.
Mittlerweile haben sie anscheinend irgendwo auf dem
Staatsmarkt welche erstanden oder so, weiß ich nicht.
Zumindest Unity Media hat zu wenig
IPv6-Adressen.
Ey, Schwachsinn, zu wenig IPv4-Adressen.
Big Brain.
Deswegen, was macht Unity Media?
Unity Media, ähm,
muss ja ihren Leuten IPv4
zur Verfügung stellen.
Ohne IPv4 funktioniert das
Internet 2019 leider nur zur Hälfte.
So, das Problem ist jetzt, dass sie zu wenig IPv4-Adressen
haben für jeden Kunden, um dem
eine IPv4-Adresse zu geben.
Deswegen sagt
Unity Media, gut, dann kriegen
unsere Kunden einfach nur noch IPv6-Adressen
und
mehrere Kunden teilen sich
eine externe
IPv4-Adresse.
So, das ist
der Gedanke dahinter, hinter Dual-Stack-Light.
Dual-Stack bedeutet ja eigentlich nur,
du kriegst eine IPv4 und eine IPv6-Adresse.
Ähm...
Und
Dual-Stack-Light bedeutet
im Endeffekt, du kriegst nur eine vollwertige
IPv6-Adresse, dafür
eine private IPv4-Adresse, die über
IPv6 getunnelt wird. Also,
funktioniert folgendermaßen,
du brauchst ja von deinem
Rechner Zugriff aufs Internet.
Sowohl IPv4 als
auch IPv6. Manche Sachen gibt es
schlicht, da kann man doch nicht in IPv6.
Oder vielleicht hat man ein Gerät, was
kein IPv6 kann.
So, und, ähm,
IPv6 ist kein Problem. Hast du
eine IPv6-Adresse, hat
der Rechner im Internet, den du aufrufen
willst, so wie Google zum Beispiel eine IPv6-Adresse,
ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann geht das direkt von deinem Host
zum Server im Internet und vom Server im Internet
zu deinem Host. Überhaupt kein Problem.
Ah, hier ist eine Firewall dazwischen, dass
das nicht so ohne weiteres geht. Aber
das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Bei
IPv4 sieht es mittlerweile schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Du teilst dir nämlich eine IPv4-Adresse
mit, ähm,
mehreren Kunden
bei Unity Media. So, und
hier ist Unity Media an der Stelle.
Unity Media macht für dich nochmal
NAT. Also sprich, das ist
ganz, ganz grob gesagt,
du hast eine private IPv4-Adresse,
also sowas wie 10.10.10.10
oder sowas,
und, ähm,
die wird quasi
über deine IPv6-Leitung
zu Unity Media geschickt. Also IPv4
wird verpackt in IPv6,
wird zu Unity Media verschickt,
in Unity Media wird es wieder ausgepackt,
dort teilst du dir
mit, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 150, ich hab
keine Ahnung, wie viele es wirklich sind, ne,
mit 150 Kunden ist rein aus der Luft
gegriffen die Zahl, ja, Kunden
eine public IPv4-Adresse,
hier wird
das übersetzt,
dann geht's von Unity Media zum Server,
stellvertretend für dich, der Server zurück
zu Unity Media,
Unity Media guckt nach, wer hat die
Anfrage ursprünglich gestellt,
packt das Ganze wieder ein in IPv6,
schickt's zu dir zurück,
äh, schickt's zu dir zurück,
dann wird das Ganze wieder ausgepackt und, ähm,
wobei, ne, ja, oder?
Ne, bis zum Router geht das Ganze, bis zum Router geht das Ganze.
Äh, hier wird das Ganze wieder ausgepackt
und, ähm, sein Host kriegt's auf
seiner privaten IPv4-Adresse.
Hat man das verstanden?
Ich mein, das war jetzt bisschen
big, big brain.
So, und das Problem ist, bei der ganzen
Geschichte,
wenn man vom Internet per IPv6
zugreifen möchte, kein Problem, geht, direkt.
Wenn jetzt irgendjemand,
vom Internet aus,
wenn er jetzt sagt, hey, ich würde gerne
einen Minecraft-Server laufen lassen bei mir,
ähm,
dann hast du das Problem, da müsste ja jemand
aus dem Internet
auf deinen Server kommen.
Dein Server steht nicht nur hinter deinem Router, sondern
steht hinter nem Carrier
Create NAT, also sprich hinter nem Provider NAT
bei Unity Media. Und Unity Media
gibt dir garantiert nicht die Zugangsdaten
für ihren Router,
um dort Port Forwarding
auf deine private IPv4-Adresse
einzurichten.
Ey, da müssten wir
echt mal bei Unity Media anrufen und fragen,
sag mal, sieht das aus, krieg ich Zugriff?
Krieg ich Zugriff auf euren NAT-Router?
Ich würd mir gern ein paar
Port-Weiterleitungen einrichten.
Mal gucken, wahrscheinlich ist dieser Typ
an der Hotline, da sagt er nur, alter,
was willst du? Ich hab keine Ahnung, wovon du sprichst, ey.
Peppy, who are you?
Twitch Prime, dankeschön, pock.
Samus Climer
Prime, Samus Climer,
na, na, nice.
Ja, das ist, äh,
Duels der Clyde, Carrier Create NAT.
Also,
der übelste Bullshit ist das.
Also, übelster Müll, warte mal kurz.
Max Mutors.
Ja,
so funktioniert das mit Unity Media.
Also, es ist Crap. Deswegen kannst du dir auch
keinen Minecraft-Server laufen lassen.
Nicht so ohne
weiteres. Du kannst natürlich was
machen. Was geht ist,
du könntest einen weiteren Tunnel bauen.
Du könntest einen weiteren Tunnel bauen, mal angenommen
du hättest hier im Internet,
mal angenommen du hättest hier im Internet, achso,
übrigens mit dieser, mit dieser Geschichte,
weil irgendjemand was von wegen NAT-Typ,
NAT-Typ, äh, geschrieben hat.
Also, nachdem du hier nie
die Möglichkeit hast, Ports weiterzuleiten,
wirst du auch nie auf deiner Konsole angezeigt
bekommen, dass du irgendwie einen offenen NAT-Typ
oder so hast. Auch wenn es einen NAT-Typ an sich
überhaupt nicht gibt.
So, und was du machen kannst ist,
mal angenommen, also das erste, was du machen kannst
ist Unity Media auf den Sack gehen. Das habe ich
damals auch gemacht. Ich bin in ein paar Wochen
auf Twitter öffentlich auf den Keks gegangen. Ich meine,
ich habe den Vorteil, dass ich, ich glaube, irgendwie
irgendwie 22.000
oder so Follower habe auf Twitter. Da ist
das natürlich eine gewisse, ein bisschen
mehr Druck,
sagen wir mal, dahinter,
wie wenn da andere
vielleicht schreiben auf Twitter, ja.
Das heißt, Unity Media hat mich dann umgestellt
und was du machen kannst
ist, natürlich kann man von
hier nach außen
einen Tunnel aufbauen. Also mal angenommen,
du würdest dir hier einen Server mieten im Internet
und du
baust einen Tunnel auf von deinem Host
zu diesem IPv4-Server
und dieser Server hat eine Public IPv4-Adresse,
was er ja haben muss, sonst würdest du ihn gar nicht erreichen.
Dann kannst du einen Tunnel aufbauen von da dahin
und kannst dann wiederum sagen, alles
was auf diesen Server connected,
geht durch den Tunnel dahin.
Das ist aber übelst
und das passt durch die Brust ins Auge.
Weil dann gehen deine Taten
quasi in einem Tunnel
über einen Carrier Crate Nut
IPv6 Tunnel,
IPv6 entpacken zu dir wieder ein...
Also das geht aber, das geht.
Das muss auch gar nicht
komplizierter sein, das muss kein OpenVPN
oder sowas sein, da reicht eine SSH-Verbindung.
SSH von da
nach da, SSH-G
Port aufmachen, Listen
und hier Redirect. Geht, gar kein Problem.
Ist aber wirklich
eine ganz hässliche Lösung.
Wäre es nicht möglich, dass Unity Media
zu so einem Vertrag noch 1-2 Port Forwardings
dazu gibt? Möglich wäre das,
ja.
Gibt es? Richtig, es gibt keinen NAT-Typ.
Es gibt nur Ports weitergeleitet
oder Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Das ist in dem Fall ziemlich Binary,
ja. Und nicht in dieser Art
und Weise. Und auch nicht in dieser Art und Weise,
sondern halt entweder
Ports weitergeleitet oder Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Wird DS Lite
mit der Vodafone Übernahme abgeschafft?
Das glaube ich nicht, die haben nicht genug IPv4-Adressen.
Ist das Unity Media
der Fall oder haben sowas auch
andere Anbieter? Ehrlich gesagt, ich kenne
es nur von Unity Media, aber ich würde wundern, wenn das andere nicht
auch machen würden. Das ist ja die einzige Variante,
die du machen kannst. Du musst deinen Kunden
IPv4 geben
und wenn du selbst zu wenig Public-IP-Adressen
hast, hast du gelitten.
Ey, Wobblors,
ey Max,
ESP866 und ESP32
könnten per WLAN gecrashed und übernommen werden.
Vielleicht willst du das mal abschauen.
Okay.
Interessant.
Ah, nice.
Muss man dazu im WLAN sein oder reicht das, wenn man
in der Nähe ist?
Bildschirmarbeit, hast du das mal durchgelesen?
Master Feedy, willkommen
im Stream.
624.
Äh, doch, doch, doch.
Also in der Regel ist es immer viel einfacher
IPv6, also Public,
ähm,
warte mal.
Ne, ne, umgedreht.
Also, du kannst
ziemlich gut, ähm,
sagen wir mal, ne Public IPv6-Adresse
mappen auf ne interne IPv4-Adresse.
Ausgehend
ist nicht möglich.
Ausgehend, also was du nicht machen kannst,
ist, ähm, außer mit irgendeinem
Proxy, mit komischen Settings, aber in der Regel kann man
sagen, es ist nicht möglich,
mit nem Host, der ne IPv4-Adresse hat,
auf IPv6-Internet zuzugreifen. Geht nicht.
Egal, was man für
komische
Router-Rewrite-Dinger macht.
Liegt einfach daran,
weil nen Host mit IPv4
auch nur DNS-IPv4-Auflösung macht.
Unter anderem.
Erhöht sich durch solch
eine Geschichte der Ping in Spielen.
Klar. Klar.
Du hast ja hier ne Zwischenstufe drinne,
die wahrscheinlich auch ordentlich brummt unter ner Last,
weil das ist ja nicht, da ist ja nicht nur einer,
der da drüber geht.
Es wird alles doppelt und dreifach ein- und ausgepackt.
Da hast du, da hast du mit Sicherheit nen höheren Ping.
Es hält sich jetzt in Grenzen.
Es wird jetzt nicht so sein, dass du auf einmal,
dass du, keine Ahnung, normalerweise nen 6er Ping hast
und danach nen 50er Ping.
Aber ein paar Millisekunden wird das schon ausmachen.
Der Schokoklaus
sagt hallo.
Moin Schokoklaus.
Machst du eigentlich DevOps auf der Arbeit?
Kann man so nennen.
Das ist ja der neueste Trend, dass man das DevOps nennt.
Ja. Gut.
Jetzt installieren wir uns Linux Mint.
Nattyp ist, ob man per
UPnP Ports freigeben kann
oder ob man punch holen muss.
Ähm.
Das Problem ist,
dass so Geschiss wie
COD und sowas nicht punch holt.
Dazu bräuchten sie ja nen,
dazu bräuchten sie irgendeinen Server in der Mitte.
Und du müsstest, wenn du punch holen würdest,
was wahrscheinlich kein Mensch überhaupt
versteht, um was ich jetzt erzähle, dann bräuchte
du diesen ganzen, diesen ganzen Geschiss nicht von,
von wegen Ports weiterleiten für die Konsole.
Skype macht das ja auch so. Skype macht das ja auch so
für, für Voice.
Skype-Kommunikation ist, ist
P2P. Allerdings mit nem
Vermittlungsserver, der die Nat-Ports
aufmacht. Das funktioniert
schon, aber da haben, da haben Sony und Microsoft
und Call of Duty Geschiss kein Bock
drauf.
Okay. Forever.
Starten. Geht's.
Was ist das Maximum,
was Telekom bei dir anbietet?
Beziehungsweise, wieso willst du bei Unity Media bleiben?
Äh. Ich war bei der Telekom. Ich war bei Telekom.
Ich hatte die ganze Zeit nen Unity Media Anschluss
und nen Telekom Anschluss.
Beides. Und das war mir jetzt
mit der Zeit, ehrlich gesagt, einfach zu teuer.
Deswegen hab ich jetzt gesagt, okay,
Unity Media bietet, äh,
das bessere Gesamtpaket bei mir.
Und sie haben mir garantiert, dass ich mein IPv4
behalte. Ansonsten
flame ich die halt wieder auf Twitter. Zwei Wochen am Stück.
Ähm.
Unity Media hat
440 ab. Telekom hätte maximal bei mir
250 daun, dafür 100 ab.
Ähm. Dafür hat Unity
Media das bessere Gesamtpaket,
was, ähm, weil auch noch, weil auch
der Fernseher dabei ist. Ich brauch nämlich eh nen Kabelanschluss.
Und das lohnt sich nicht.
Zwei Anschlüsse zu bezahlen.
Das ist deutlich billiger, wenn ich nur Unity Media nehme.
Und, was bei mir
noch dazu kommt, ist, dass bei mir die Telekom
entgegen irgendwie allen anderen in
Deutschland gefühlt, weniger
stabil war, als Unity Media.
Okay, wir machen mal ne neue VM.
Custom.
Logstation.
Next. Linux.
Was haben wir runtergeladen? Äh.
Mint. Ja, das ist ein Ubuntu.
Sorry. So, Leute. Jetzt kommen die ganzen
Ubuntu-Aussprache-Leute wieder.
Ubuntu ist das. Ubuntu.
Weil, weil die Leute immer
draufstehen, wenn man den Kram, ähm,
besonders stylisch,
stylisch ausspricht, ja.
Ubuntu.
Ähm, so. Das ist
Mint.
Ähm.
Eine CPU, drei Kerne.
Sind wir mal großzügig, machen wir mal drei Kerne.
Warte mal, wie viele Kerne habe ich?
Habe ich vier oder sechs? Sechs Kerne habe ich, ne?
Sechs. Sechs Kerne habe ich.
Habt ihr mal nicht gemerkt, du bist fail.
Früher, Leute, ich habe sechs Kerne, ja. Früher
konnte ich mir, konnte ich von jeder
aktuellen CPU, konnte ich hier runterbeten,
fast schon, wie viel Cash
der Kram hat, ja. Und heute
überlege ich, wie viele Kerne meine eigene CPU hat.
Das ist, äh, das ist nicht
Big Brain, das ist Small Brain.
Wo steht's überhaupt, wie viele Kerne man hat?
Ach, hier. Sechs Cores.
Okay, dann reichen drei Kerne aus.
2G RAM reichen auch aus.
Ähm, Dat ist okay.
Alles, Create Virtual Disk
20G ist auch gut.
Finish. Okay.
Also, installieren
wir mal das neue Linux Mint und gucken uns das
Ganze an. Einen Drucker brauchen wir nicht,
eine Soundkarte lassen wir dran, USB-Controller
lassen wir... USB-Controller
machen wir aus, weil der sich manchmal meine
Maus oder mein Audio-Interface crabt bei einer
neuen VM. Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
So, ISO-Image.
Download.
Linux Mint.
So, schauen wir mal.
Wie das läuft. Also, unsere letzten zwei
Tests. Elementary hat mich ja sehr
überzeugt das letzte Mal, von der Optik her.
Äh, MX Linux hat mir das letzte Mal
überhaupt nicht so gefallen.
Lull bin auch gerade am Linux Mint installiert, nice.
Small Brain Emote. Threehead.
Nee, Threehead ist eher ein Emote,
wo einer vor die Wand gerannt ist.
Wow.
Huge Sound Effects.
Und Huge Auflösung.
Komm, wir scalen das Ganze mal.
Wir sagen jetzt...
ging das nochmal? Äh...
Restretch.
So.
Huge Auflösung auf jeden Fall schon mal hier.
Install.
Wie wäre es mit Gentoo testen?
Das können wir mal machen.
Da brauchen wir aber viel Zeit.
Wobei das meiste kompiliert relativ schnell.
Ich sehe es ja bei meinem
Manjaro. Alle Custom-Pakete
musst du dann auch selbst kompilieren.
Plus das halt fertige
Skripts und so dabei sind. Bisschen wie bei Gentoo eigentlich.
Ähm, das Kompilieren geht in der Regel
relativ schnell.
Spielst du BFPC2
auf Origin oder auf Steam?
Auf...
Origin.
Sind die Server getrennt? Ich dachte die...
Die Server sind nicht getrennt, oder?
Bad Company 2, Origin und Steam
sollten doch die gleichen Server sein.
Ähm...
Jaja, wir testen ja irgendwann auch nochmal
Hannah Montana Linux.
Okay, Englisch. Ja.
Das ist der normale Ubuntu Installer.
Gea.
Geaman.
Äh...
No-Dead-Keys. Wollen wir haben.
No-Dead-Keys sorgt dafür, dass
hier links und Tilde
und dieses Hütchen und der
das Zirkumflex, wie sich das ja glaube ich
nennt, dass das ordentlich funktioniert.
Oh.
Oh. Ja, mach mal.
Bad Company 1 ist noch
Gamesbyte. Keine Ahnung. Bad Company 1
ist Konsolen-exklusiv. Können wir da eigentlich spielen.
Next.
Continue. Berlin. Continue.
Username.
Okay. Wer hat zuletzt gesubbt?
Wer hat zuletzt gesa...
gesubbt? Man kann sagen, wer hat zuletzt
gesackt. Nein, wer zuletzt gesubbt
hat natürlich. Ähm...
Das ist zu spät.
Hahaha.
MSIT. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh, das ist zu spät jetzt.
Das war zwar Big Brain
Fast Reaction Sub.
Aber das
zählt jetzt nicht, wenn ich das gesagt hab.
Wer hat, wer hat denn jetzt davor gesubbt?
Peppy, who are you?
Okay, dann heißt unser Linux
heißt jetzt Peppy.
Peppy.
Na, na, komm. Dann machen wir's. Komm, wir sind
mal so. Username ist MSIT.
Und ähm...
Computer Name ist Peppy. Passwort 123456.
Ich hoffe, ich kann mir das merken, weil
mein Username ist sonst immer Test.
Machen wir's so.
Require my Passwort. Ja, continue.
So, lassen wir mal installieren.
Noch nicht September.
Stimmt, das wollte ich mal. Was genau
ist das eigentlich? Während es installiert,
guck mal, was ist eigentlich genau?
Was ist eigentlich nochmal September gewesen?
123456 ist fair Passwort,
ja. Ich versteh auch nicht, was mit
dem los ist. Okay, September.
Seit September was introduced in 2017.
Okay.
Am 3. Heute geht's los. Ab
1 Uhr PT.
1 Uhr PT ist
22 Uhr. Also
in dreieinhalb Stunden.
50% off Tier 1 Subs.
Oh, da muss ich, da müsste ich ja eigentlich
heute nach 22 Uhr nochmal on gehen.
Für mehr Sellout.
Hem Sudi, dankeschön.
Twitch Prime.
Kann man die überhaupt
donaten? Gute Frage, lesen wir mal.
Ehm, made on a
web browser or your desktop app so you can
support even more of
Okay, das heißt
im Endeffekt, du kannst deine
Kohle einfach auf mehr Leute verteilen.
Ah ja, gut.
Ach okay, guck mal, man kann
sogar, man kann sogar
Subscription extenden.
Für die Hälfte des Preises. Das ist doch
nice.
Also wer richtig pfeifert ist,
der extendet natürlich jetzt.
Ne, also wer clever
ist, der, ne, wartet
einfach noch bis morgen oder so mit dem
Extenden.
Streamers continue to receive
full value. Ja, das ist nice.
Okay, im Prinzip
ist das
eigentlich nur, dass die Subs jetzt
die Hälfte kosten.
Oder ein bisschen weniger als die Hälfte.
Gilt diesmal nur, wenn man
nie Sub war?
Ne, das haben doch
ihr eben gerade gesagt.
You can also continue your subscription
for, ach so, if you
have any active gift subs
or Twitch Prime, ah okay.
Das heißt, wenn man Twitch Prime
Sub ist und zu einem normalen
Sub wechselt, kostet's
quasi, irgendwie nur
50 Prozent.
Und, oder wenn man einen Gifte-Sub
hat und auf einen Sub wechselt.
Na gut, die wollen halt den Anreiz schaffen, dass die Leute
eine Autoverlängerung für den Sub machen.
Okay, was gibt's sonst noch?
Äh, Custom Emotes.
Habt ihr eigentlich schon die ganzen
Emotes gesehen, Leute, die wir hier haben?
Huge Emotes, ja?
Wir haben ganze vier Emotes von 14
oder so, hab ich schon drinne.
Ich muss mich, ich muss mich morgen mal hinsetzen
und noch ein paar Emotes mir
aus den
Fingern saugen, die man machen könnte.
Ich muss ja sagen, mein persönlicher
Favorit ist tatsächlich, äh,
der quasi Cup HD,
Wub Cup, weil das hat keiner
sonst. Die haben alle den normalen
Cup und wir haben den Wub Cup.
Wub Lull gibt's schon bei
der Twitch TV. Ja, ich weiß.
Ich hab Wub Lull,
hab ich auch, hab ich auch, ähm,
mit minimalen Änderungen
äh, geklaut.
Wieso kein Monk KW,
weil ich Monk KW nicht mag.
Monk KW gefällt mir nicht.
Monk KG ist nice,
Monk KX ist nice,
Monk KS ist nice,
aber Monk KW mag ich nicht.
Monk KX, ihr könnt Monk KX machen, zum Beispiel.
Das haben die wenigsten drin.
Monk KW mag ich
nicht.
Wenn ich Monk KW brauche, also wenn ich
einen haben will, der die Augen besonders
groß macht, nämlich Monk KG,
wann wird
denn am Staubsauger gezockt?
Wir haben letztens Custom-Programm
aus dem Staubsauger laufen lassen im Stream.
Sigi freut, Twitch Prime, nice,
huge, big, big brain, dankeschön.
Okay, was gibt's denn
sonst noch? Subscriber-Badge,
Leute, ab nächsten Monat, ne,
ich sag's ja nur ungern,
ab nächsten Monat brauch ich eine 3-Monats-
Subscriber-Badge.
Geht ganz schön schnell, oder?
Zeit geht echt schnell rum.
Wo hast du die Stimme her für mein Meme-Board?
Das ist ein Text-to-Speech-Service,
ein koreanischer
oder japanischer Text-to-Speech-Service,
den, ich weiß aber nicht mal, wie der
Kram hieß, Voice Text?
Voice Text?
Japan oder so?
Da kannst du dir im Prinzip, kannst irgendwas reinschreiben
und das liest das Ding vor.
Und ich hab's halt so eingebaut, dass der quasi,
dass man Text eingeben kann,
er lädt das hoch und lädt sich dann die Datei runter
und speichert sich's. Weil sonst müsste ich jedes Mal
hier eine halbe Minute warten, bis der was ausspricht.
Ich muss ja sagen, meine Lieblings,
äh,
äh, Voice, Voice-Geschichten hier im Meme-Board
ist ja eindeutig, ist eindeutig die Kombination
hier.
Das ist immer noch die beste Kombination!
Der Raptor!
3-1-1-2!
Twitch Prime!
Der Durchschnitts-IQ ist heute ja schon so hoch.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, danke schön.
Wo wen haben wir denn sonst noch?
Den, den Sole-Mann.
Oh, da hab ich verkuckt...
Ah, ne, der Sole-Mann sagt nur hallo. Hi, Solemann.
Okay, mal gucken, ob, ob Mint installiert hat.
Peristall, bam.
Please remove installation media.
Hab ich schon, oder?
Warum noch nicht?
Wie, wie löscht man das eigentlich so?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man das löscht, aber
wir drücken jetzt einfach mal Enter.
Never.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob Linux Mint VMware Tools dabei hat.
Mal gucken, ob Linux Mint VMware Tools dabei hat.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Wow!
Sie haben anscheinend keine VMware Tools dabei.
Dann müssen wir erstmal VMware Tools installieren.
Huge Password.
Rollenschenkel Kuro.
RIP Headphone User. Warum? Was war?
Hat es irgendwie Geräusche gemacht?
Ach, du meinst hier das Ding.
Oh, laut war das nicht.
Okay, wie hieß der Kram nochmal, den man VMware Tools...
Wie hieß der Mist nochmal, den man installieren muss?
VMware Tools Desktop oder so, ne?
Kann es sein, dass die keine VMware...
Nee, nicht VMware Tools, VMware Tools hieß das.
VMware Tools? Nee, wie?
Guck mal, der Chat weiß es schon.
Der Chat weiß es schon wieder.
Open VMware Tools Desktop.
Genau.
Das war das.
Install.
Yes.
Okay.
Zack.
Erst die Tools selber und dann den Desktop.
Nee, die wird sich wahrscheinlich als Abhängigkeit mitbringen.
Sehr schön.
Okay, Linux Mint ist am Start mit ordentlicher Auflösung.
Ähm.
Ja.
Was testen wir denn?
Was haben wir das letzte Mal immer getestet?
Genau.
Erstmal gucken, ob wir uns irgendwie zurechtfinden.
Was ist standardmäßig dabei?
Firefox Terminal.
Firefox ist lahm wie immer.
Ähm.
Nee, Firefox braucht einfach ein bisschen länger bis es startet meistens.
Danach ist es schnell.
Was haben wir für ein Terminal?
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Gnome Terminal.
Ist allerdings ein...
Was ist das denn?
Ein Gnome Terminal.
Gnome Terminal ist auch mal Lieblingsterminal.
Passt.
Moin, der Provokateur.
Auch am Start.
Was haben wir für Start?
Standard Schriften dabei.
Haben wir da irgendwas Sinnvolles?
Moment, wo konnte man das nochmal einstellen?
General.
Moment, wo war das nochmal mit den...
Wo ging denn nochmal die Schrift ein?
Das war doch hier irgendwas sonst.
Ach, Custom Font hier unten.
Haben wir, haben wir sowas wie Roboto Hack oder so?
Nee, haben wir nicht dabei.
Haben die das in den...
Hack.
Haben die Hack Font?
Haben die irgendwie sowas?
Ja.
Fonds Hack.
Ohhhh.
Sehr gut.
Bester Font, den braucht man immer.
Hack Font.
Welche VM benutzt du?
Das ist äh, vor allem bei Workstation.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir Hack auswählen können.
Hack, bester Font.
Da ist er.
Das gefällt mir schon mal gut, das ist schön durchdacht.
Erstmal ein bisschen größer machen, den ganzen Mist.
Ja, das sieht doch jetzt nach einem ordentlichen Terminal aus.
Hier.
Transparenz noch ausschalten, dann ist alles gut.
Okay, das sieht doch jetzt schon mal nach einem ordentlichen Terminal aus, das gefällt mir.
Das kann man verwenden auf jeden Fall.
Was, was ich auch ganz gut finde, dass die hier den ganzen, ganzen Kram halbwegs an den richtigen Stellen haben,
weil das geht mir bei Ubuntu immer auf den Keks, wenn es auf einmal hier links ist.
Was ist dein favorite MMO of all time?
Dark Edge of Camelot.
Not even close.
Beste.
360.
No.
Wollte ich nicht drücken gerade.
Dark Edge of Camelot, beste.
Für immer, wird für immer beste MMO bleiben, zumindest bei mir im Kopf.
Ja, aber damit kann man arbeiten, das war schon mal ganz nice.
T-Mox, ja auf jeden Fall.
Also als Standard, standardmäßig.
Was haben wir eigentlich für ein WIM dabei?
Haben wir ein WIM dabei?
Ne, haben wir nicht.
Also Install.
Die GTK WIM.
Die installiere ich bloß, weil dann auch die Clipboard Erweiterung immer dabei sind.
Äh.
T-Mox und Hardtop.
Brauchen wir auch.
Muss.
Ohne geht nicht.
Neo WIM WIM.
So ein großer Unterschied ist es doch gar nicht.
Die sind ein bisschen eingeschlafen bei Neo WIM.
Die ganzen Background-Task-Geschichten und so haben die jetzt im richtigen WIM auch.
Also die sind, die Neo WIM Leute sind ein bisschen eingeschlafen.
Ne, SL brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen, okay.
Haben wir ASCII-Quarium?
Kein ASCII-Quarium.
Na gut.
Aber T-Mox.
T-Mox.
T-Mox ist am Start.
Ist doch schon mal was.
T-Mox ist am Start und Hardtop für Auslastung läuft auch.
Da sind auch schon die wichtigsten Sachen drauf.
Gefällt mir gut.
Man merkt einfach auch, dass ein Ubuntu drunter ist.
Ubuntu.
Ähm.
So, Google.
Gehen wir mal auf YouTube.
Oder was ist denn für eine Default-Suche drinne hier?
Test.
Igitt.
Yahoo.
Ist das euer Ernst?
Yahoo-Suche.
Wer verwendet denn sowas?
So.
Stellt man den Kram mittlerweile ein?
Ne.
Yahoo.
Wer macht denn sowas, ja?
Search.
Äh.
Ach du Scheiße, wo gehen das denn?
Die Google ist da gar nicht dabei?
Dann nehmen wir DuckDuckGo.
DuckDuckGo ist auch gut.
Ich bin, ich hab mich, wie geht es euch eigentlich?
Ähm.
So die letzten, so das letzte halbe Jahr oder so, ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich immer mehr
bei DuckDuckGo lande.
Oftmals.
Subscriber.
Oh, das kann ich nicht aussprechen.
Haha.
Konnte ich das das letzte Mal aussprechen?
IceFreak?
Doch, IceFreak.
Klar kann ich das aussprechen.
Neatspeak, kein Problem für mich.
Easy.
DuckDuckGo ist ganz nice, wegen den, ihren Bangs.
Was ist, was ist denn ein Bang auf DuckDuckGo?
Das einzige, was ich bei DuckDuckGo ein bisschen vermisse, ist der Google Cash.
Allerdings, Google Cash passt ja irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Also, wenn ihr euch mal die Google-Cache anschaut, dann wisst ihr, dass das Google Cash
ist.
Also, wenn ihr euch mal die Google-Cache anschaut, dann wisst ihr, dass das Google Cash ist.
Also, ich muss sagen, ich vermeide Google nicht irgendwie wegen irgendwelchem Tracking-Kram.
Ähm.
Ist natürlich auch legitim.
Achso, du kannst direkt auf Google suchen, ja.
Ich überlege mir bloß gerade, wo das, wo das, wo das, wo das Google ...
So, da ist es.
Ja, da ist es.
Es ist.
Ja, es ist.
Ja, es ist, ja, es ist.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist.
Das war's.
Dann, dann, dann, dann.
Ja, dann, dann, dann.
So.
Ja, dann, dann.
Ja.
Warum ich angefangen habe
DuckDuckGo zu verwenden
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr
Was war denn der Grund
Ich weiß nur noch, dass ich mit manchen Sachen auf Google
Überhaupt nicht zufrieden war
Und wo ich dann festgestellt habe
DuckDuckGo funktioniert das viel besser
Ich weiß es nicht mehr
Oh, Dark Theme, ja
Wo ist es, wo ist das Dark Theme
Das brauchen wir, ganz wichtig
Dark Theme
Das ist viel angenehmer
Die dunkle Ente
Ich weiß es ehrlich
Ich kann es euch jetzt nicht sagen, ich weiß es nicht
Komm, gleich wird er irgendwelche komischen
Streaming, illegalen Streaming Seiten
Am Start, wenn du hier auf DuckDuckGo suchst
Ähm
Ne, keine Ahnung
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war, aber ich weiß
Dass mir irgendwas auf Google so auf den Keks gegangen ist
Dass ich mittlerweile oftmals DuckDuckGo verwende
Gut, also
Mal gucken, wie YouTube läuft
Ob alles dabei ist, was man braucht für YouTube
Ich meine, YouTube selbst ist ja mittlerweile rein
HTML5, ja, da sollte
Eigentlich ohne Probleme funktionieren
Aber man weiß nie
So sieht also die Startseite aus
Von YouTube, wenn man noch nie drauf war
Trending
Ach du Scheiße, was ist das denn, was da trendet
Meine Güte
Alter YouTuber
Ist da irgendwas
Drinnen
Was man überhaupt, ja, das kann man aufmachen
Okay, funktioniert das Video
Okay, erstmal schön fett die Werbung
Natürlich
Erstmal skippen
Funktioniert, funktioniert
Funktioniert in HD, funktioniert in 4K
4K ist in der VM immer eklig
Sogar 4K funktioniert nice in der VM
Was hat man für eine Auslastung dabei
Oh, sehr gut
Sehr gut, sehr gut
Das ist ziemlich gut
4K Video flüssig in der VM
Ähm
Und quasi nur ein CPU Kern komplett ausgelastet
In der VM ist ja leider
Video
Nicht, ähm
Nicht, äh, GPU decodet, ja
Das suckt
Du kannst, du kannst in, in
Du kannst eh nix Hardware beschleunigt decoden in der VM
Das haben sie bis heute nicht hingekriegt
Das ärgert mich auch ein bisschen
Weil es müsste technisch möglich sein
Dass du, ähm
Den, den H.264 Decoder
Vom Host verwendest
Wenn die da einen Treiber für bereitstellen würden
Gibt's leider nicht
So, gucken wir uns mal an, Battlefield 60 Hertz
Oh, schon ein bisschen mehr
So ein bisschen mehr
Auslastung
Aber es läuft gut
Es läuft wirklich okay
Igitt, der Opera Gaming Browser
War mal ganz schick
Also, es ist okay
Ich mein, die CPU Auslastung ist natürlich krass, ne
Also quasi zwei CPU Kerne
1,5 CPU Kerne voll für ein Video
Aber so ist es halt, wenn man kein Hardware Decoding hat
So, dann probieren wir das nochmal
Mit dem Addon aus
Den jetzt, den jetzt jemand vorgeschlagen hat
Aber sollte keinen großen Unterschied machen
Weil alles CPU decoded ist
Ähm
Der Bildschirmarbeit Tor ist am Start
Zwei Monate, huge
Nächsten Monat brauch ich statt neuer Subpatches
Wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
H.264ify, ne?
Ja
Für Firefox
Huge Addon
23.000 User
Ich glaub man musste gar nix machen
Einfach installieren, ne?
Got it
Block 60 Hertz?
60 FPS Videos?
Warum?
Ach, guck mal
Da zeigt er gar kein 4K an
Kann das sein?
Dass er das nicht mag im Firefox?
Oder kann das sein, dass das 1044p
Prinzipiell nur verfügbar ist in VP9?
Weiß ich nicht
Natürlich ist es in Full HD
Braucht das Ganze natürlich deutlich weniger CPU Last, ne?
Naja, deutlich
Braucht weniger CPU Last
Wir können das mal ausprobieren, ob das Video tatsächlich nur verfügbar ist in VP9
Remove Extension
Remove
Wir installieren jetzt einfach mal eine Runde YouTube Download
Search
Bestes Tool
YouTube DL
Weiß gar nicht, ob das dabei ist
Das ist so ein Programm, wo ich mir überlegen würde, über Paketmanager zu installieren, weil sich da oft was ändert
Gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert
So, und ich lade jetzt mal mein eigenes Video runter oder ich lass mir mal anzeigen, was es für Objekte gibt, ne?
Also, wenn es so Optionen für mein eigenes Video gibt
Warum mach ich das eigentlich...
YouTube DL
Minus F
Minus groß F
Einfügen
Okay YouTube DL ist zu oder war das minus, minus Klein F
Ich glaub, das YouTube DL ist zu alt
Das YouTube DL ist zu alt
Was im, was im, im Repo drin ist
Dann müssen wir uns YouTube DL so installieren
Groß F für die Option hab ich doch
Geht nicht
So alt.
Anzeige ist raus, genau.
YouTube, DL, GitHub.
Wie installiert man das eigentlich?
Ich habe das immer nur aus den Arch-User-Repos installiert.
Installation.
Jawoll, hauptsache mal irgendwie Curl, Curl-Pipen irgendwo hin.
Was download ich da eigentlich?
Egal, einfach Curl ausführen, runterladen, gut ist.
Allerdings hier wollen wir lokal hin und nicht System.
Das was ist? Das ist ein Go?
Ist das Go? Oder was ist das?
In was ist das programmiert?
Ah, Pyson.
Binary Pyson.
Pyson.
Was?
Ach, weil ich Sudo davor gemacht habe.
Warum mache ich da auch Sudo davor?
Bisschen beknackt.
CH own und jetzt auf Peppy.
Ne, Test.
Test heißt er ja.
Der User.
Okay, CH Mod.
Okay, jetzt können wir das Ganze nochmal machen.
Allerdings mit meinem lokalen YouTube-DL.
Und jetzt sehen wir mal, was hat denn das YouTube für Video?
Okay, VP9, VP9.
Also 1440 ist nur in VP9 verfügbar.
Was?
Sagt rum?
Das ist doch ein Problem.
Was mein Video hat, oder?
Weil ich habe mir letztens erst von der Hexe
ein Video runtergeladen.
Oder war das vielleicht bei ihm auch nur 1080p?
Ein Battlefield-Gameplay von ihm runtergeladen.
Und ich bilde mir ein, das konnte ich in der besten Quali...
Alter, geh weg, Werbung.
Das konnte ich in der besten Quali runterladen in 1440p als H.264.
Oder war das nur 1080p?
Okay, war nur 1080p.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ansonsten wäre eigentlich auch kein Problem,
weil das Schöne ist ja, dass ich das Video nicht veröffentliche.
Ich habe das Video nicht veröffentlichen können.
Man hat hier so viel Software dabei.
Es ist überhaupt kein Problem zu sagen,
YouTube Download.
Sagen wir jetzt hier F.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie das geht.
Wir wollen die beste Videoqualität
plus irgendwie
halbwegs gute Audioqualität runterladen.
So, und dann ist es super easy.
Man kann nämlich einfach das Video konvertieren,
wenn man FFM-Pack hat.
Okay, das lerne ich jetzt nicht runter.
Das ist nicht los.
Zumindest kann man einfach FFM-Packen
FFM-Pack installieren
und gut ist.
Und FFM-Pack ist eine Sache, die braucht man eh immer.
Vielleicht schon drauf.
Ne.
FFM-Pack braucht man eh immer.
Abort.
FFM-Pack beste.
Ohne FFM-Pack gehe ich nicht mehr aus dem Haus.
Also, ich muss sagen, bisher
sehr hochgefott...
sehr unproblematische
Distribution hier. Gefällt mir gut.
Vor allem besser als RPM-Gefuddel.
Rund 50 Viewer. Ja, übelst huge.
Seit ich hier Sellout gemacht habe auf YouTube, ne.
Einmal den Stream verlinkt
und einmal einen Community-Post auf YouTube gemacht.
Gibt es die übelsten Viewer.
Das ist mega nice.
Pog.
Poggers. Pogchamp.
Habe ich überhaupt noch irgendwas anderes hier drin? Ne.
Huge.
Ich würde sagen,
da müssen wir mal die Kamera getten hier.
Oh. Oh mein Gott.
Da Phobias.
Twitch Prime. Nice. Dankeschön.
Easy.
So.
Also, Linux Mint gefällt mir bisher ganz gut.
Was könnte man noch ausprobieren?
Ich meine, die Pakete müssen wir nicht gucken.
Das ist ein ganz normales Ubuntu.
Ubuntu 18.04.
Da gibt es nichts zusätzliches, was man groß gucken muss.
Oh. Das geht da unten ab.
Ähm.
Datei-Manager mit der Standard-Nautilus sein ohne irgendwas.
Mir gefällt ehrlich gesagt das, das, das.
Mir gefällt die Optik von, von, äh, Mint nicht.
Das ist irgendwie...
Wow.
Was jetzt?
Monka schlieren bilden.
Ähm. Also, die Default-GUI gefällt mir nicht.
Also, das Default-Theme gefällt mir nicht.
Wir gucken mal.
Äh. Wie ändert man das jetzt?
Ah, das Monka. Gucken wir mal, wie man was ändert.
Sag mal, ey, wie spackt das übelst rum gerade?
Was ist das?
Wie ändert man das hier?
Themes.
Settings.
Age Remove.
Yes.
Keine Ahnung, was das tut.
Ah.
Och, das ist ja schön.
Man hat sogar einen Team-Manager mit dabei.
Das ist, das ist huge.
Und.
Och, guck mal, die haben ja noch viel mehr.
Nice.
Dark Blue.
Und jetzt?
Ach, ne, man muss die Icons komplett ändern, ne?
Dark Blue.
Gibt es, ähm, kann man nicht, kann man nicht einfach alles, alles auf einmal ändern lassen?
Kann man nicht alles auf einmal ändern lassen?
Anscheinend nicht, ja.
Ist ja doof, dass man nicht hier einfach einen Button hat, äh, Blue-Theme und gut ist.
So muss man das jetzt hier quasi...
Ich mein, es ist cool, dass es geht.
Ja.
Oh, das ist doch schick.
Das ist doch schick.
Manjaro? Nee. Mint.
So ausprobieren gerade hier.
Minty Borders, Minty Dark.
Oh, das ist doch, so ist das doch was.
So ist das doch nice.
Außer, dass die Fenster Schlieren bilden, aber das...
Irgendwie, der rumspackt, wenn ich...
Wahrscheinlich, weil Frau Ember die Maus crabt oder so.
Probieren wir mal, wartet mal.
Probieren wir mal, ob das...
Ah, Frau Ember, komm.
Äh, New Exclusive Mode.
Jetzt passiert nichts mehr.
Wow, das macht einen Sound, hört ihr das?
Der Pegasound.
Moment, ich habe Exclusive Mode angemacht.
Wenn ich Exclusive Mode anmache...
Okay, das ist so eine Geschichte, wie es Windows auch hat.
Die benutze ich aber eh nicht.
Schick.
Okay, also das Dark Theme gefällt mir schon mal gut.
Was haben wir standardmäßig so dabei?
Liegt safe an Frau Ember, ja.
Denke ich auch.
Na, was macht es für Sachen?
Wir haben gerade das neue Manjaro installiert.
Äh, nicht Manjaro, das neue Mint installiert.
Gucken, wie das ist.
Echt runden Eindruck, was haben wir denn hier unten?
Ah, Update.
Der Update Manager.
Update. Okay.
Bam.
Das ist aber hier...
Der Spinner of Speed hier.
Please set up system snapshots.
Die haben einen Gui dabei für Snapshots.
Das ist cool, das gefällt mir.
Wie macht man das?
Select Snapshot.
Na gut, BTF, das kann ich nicht selecten,
weil ich habe kein BTFS-Filesystem.
Oder habe ich ein BTFS-Filesystem?
Äh, warte mal.
Ich nehme das jetzt am besten raus.
X4 ist es.
DF-T Systema.
Ah, nice.
Das finde ich das Coole, es gibt für alles
immer unter Linux, meistens zumindest,
eine simple Variante. Man muss es bloß wissen.
Oder man muss nachgucken.
X4. Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich dem sage,
ich will ein BTFS...
Das ist ja auch sowas, wo sich die Leute nicht drauf einigen können,
wenn man den Kram ausspricht.
BTFS, Butter, Better.
Next.
Ah, Device does not have a BTFS-Application.
Aber wenigstens erkennt das das Ding.
Ersync.
Find Mount.
Ah stimmt, Find Mount, ja.
Das ist auch wo du checken kannst,
ob ein Ordner ein Mount-Point ist oder nicht.
Ob ein Ordner ein Mount-Point ist oder nicht.
BtreeFS. Das juckt keiner.
Was da technisch dahinter steht.
BtreeFS.
Select Snapshot Location.
SDA1.
Next.
Wie groß wird das Snapshot jetzt sein?
Hat er das jetzt irgendwie berechnet?
Okay, ich find's auf jeden Fall cool,
dass die eine Standard-Snapshot-Geschichte dabei haben.
Ich find's wichtig, dass solche Geschichten
standardmäßig dabei sind.
Ich weiß, es ist super easy, Sachen nachzuinstallieren,
ich weiß, es ist super easy, Sachen nachzuinstallieren,
aber das ist wirklich eine runde Geschichte.
Local Mirror, yes.
Wollen wir haben, wir wollen irgendwas in Deutschland haben.
Wieso habe ich bei df-h so viele Loops?
Wie nach dem, da hast du USB-Stick dran
oder Temp gemountet irgendwie
oder was auch immer.
Das ist aber normal.
Irgendwelche Device-Dinger, die sich da reinhängen.
Ach guck mal, man kann...
Also ich muss sagen, ich find das echt gut.
Das ist total gut gemacht.
Also das ist wirklich gut gemacht für Linux-Verhältnisse.
Unter Manjaro
vuddelst du dich da erstmal ab,
bis du nen deutschen Mirror drin hast.
Gut, ich mein, außer man weiß aus dem Kopf,
die find ich cool.
Gefällt mir wirklich gut bis jetzt.
Find ich schick.
Was ich bis heute
absolut furchtbar finde unter Linux, das ist
U-Mount und nicht Un-Mount.
Ja, das mach ich...
Bei sowas vertipp ich mich auch ganz gerne mal.
Weil ich mittlerweile...
Da hab ich mich dran gewöhnt.
Midnight Commander glaub ich nicht.
Muss ich dir ehrlich auch sagen.
Verwend ich nie.
Ich verwende nie
quasi File Manager.
Ich mach das alles auf Konsole.
Entweder mit CP, es wird gemovt, sonst was.
Ne, ist nicht drauf.
So, wie macht man jetzt Updates?
Ranger!
Ich versteh den Sinn nicht, warum man Ranger verwendet.
Ganz ehrlich, leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Also jeder soll...
Ich mein, es soll im Endeffekt jeder machen, was er will.
Ich versteh den Vorteil von Ranger nicht.
Wenn ich...
Wenn ich Dateien verschieben will,
mach ich einfach ein MV.
Target.
Oder
wenn ich mir ein Bild anzeigen lassen will,
mach ich...
Wozu die schöne CLI-Ästhetik?
Ich finde,
ein CLI-File Manager ist was, was
eigentlich kein Mensch
danach gefragt hat so richtig.
Aber ich weiß, es ist beliebt.
Ich weiß aber nicht so genau, warum,
ehrlich gesagt.
Oh, da wird getriggert.
Triggern ist Jugendwort des Jahres.
Habt ihr das gelesen, ja?
Ne, doch nicht.
Was, nicht triggern?
Triggern, ja.
Ach, das hat nicht gewonnen, oder was?
Was hat gewonnen?
Okay, also,
was war?
Alles gut, das sagt kein Mensch mehr.
Alman oder Kartoffel.
Sagt eigentlich...
Ja doch, das hörst du manchmal,
aber finde ich irgendwie auch beknackt.
Prachteln habe ich noch nie gehört.
Pratan, Pratina, russisch...
Bot, klar.
Brexiting.
Sagt man das wirklich?
Bruder muss los.
Alter, das ist schon wieder so out.
Das verwendet auch kein Mensch mehr.
Bruder muss los.
Bruder muss Kos.
Nein, Bruder muss Kos
will ich suchen.
Warum? Guck, jetzt müssen wir
auf Google, falls ihr es nicht findet.
Bruder
muss Kos. Beste.
Beste hier.
Bruder muss Kos.
Ich finde das irgendwie, das ist so ein dumm
Darstellung, wie der lustig ist, ey.
Bruder muss Kos.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch hier? Butter Golem.
Das sagt auch keiner, oder?
Hier. Fettshaker.
Gaming. Anzeige ist raus.
Gleichberechtigten Beauftragte ist informiert.
Butter Golem.
Chaya.
Chabo.
Pornern.
Cringe.
Ja, das verwendet man.
Ehre genommen verwendet man auch.
Der Rest ist so.
Wir brauchen einfach möglichst viele
Wir brauchen einfach möglichst viele Wörter,
die sich irgendwie jugendlich anhören.
Das verwendet auch kein Mensch.
Bruder muss Los.
Ich mein, das ist, wenn
ich als 35-Jähriger über Jugendworte
labere. Man kann auch sagen, dass es vollkommen falsch ist.
Aber Bruder muss Los verwendet
auch echt keiner.
Cringe zu sagen ist cringe.
Flex. Ja, das wird auch verwendet.
Freundschaft plus.
Das ist eigentlich auch nicht so angesagt.
Gönniamin.
Ja, das habe ich tatsächlich schon ein paar Mal gehört.
Habibi.
Gut, arabische Wörter sind ja zur Zeit allgemein angesagt.
Äh,
Hasseln. Ja, das sagen auch manche Leute.
Kartoffel hat man schon.
Das sagt man heute noch?
Das war auch schon wieder out.
Klimanotstand.
Lachkick.
Das ist seit Jahren schon verwendet. Auch kein Mensch mehr.
Lackgesoffen ist auch uralt.
Das Ligma.
Okay.
Ich will gar nicht wissen, was es ist.
Ähm.
Schlurki.
Das verwendet auch keiner.
Mach kein Auge.
Niceness.
Ja, okay, vielleicht.
Pillepalle ist uralt. Verwendet auch kein Mensch.
Plottwist. Schlurki.
Snatched.
Stabil. Ja, das ist schon.
Das ist aber auch schon seit ein paar Jahren so.
Installiert ihr mal.
Ah, muss ich nicht installieren. Hab ich schon installiert.
Tschuldigung.
Das hat es echt da drauf geschafft.
Wirklich.
Das ist aus dem.
Das ist aus hier.
Was letzte Preis? Subreddit.
Das ist E-Mail kleiner Zeit.
Das ist.
Was letzte Preis?
Tschuldigung.
Ja gut, das ist auch angesagt.
Weilbau habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ja, aber finde ich.
Knacktes Wort.
Zerstören. Ja, das ist auch angesagt.
Ich muss ja sagen.
Wenigstens mal eine Zusammenstellung von Jugendwörtern,
die gefühlt so zu
20-25% verwendet werden.
Bruder muss Kurs.
Tschuldigung.
Stimmt, das hätte man auf DuckDuckGo suchen können.
Ja, mach mal.
Mach mal Upgrade hier.
Klimanotstands habe ich auch noch nie gehört.
Keine Ahnung.
Wieso hast du eigentlich
die komische Angewohnheit, alles zu markieren
und dann zu kopieren? Da haben wir irgendwie
ein Chatkommando für.
Ich glaube Ausrufezeichen 1
ausgeschrieben oder so.
Hast du das eigentlich mitbekommen,
dass im ersten Sonic
Trailer Gonna Go Fast mit
Bruder muss los übersetzt wurde?
Echt? Das fände ich sogar
ganz witzig.
Da hat zumindest mal irgendjemand, der ein bisschen jünger ist,
an der Übersetzung gearbeitet.
Ganz ehrlich.
Eigentlich ist das
eine ziemlich coole Übersetzung.
Bruder muss los.
Das finde ich cool. Das ist übersetzt.
Wenn das stimmt.
Keine Ahnung.
Warum guckst du unter 80 Cis-Mann
dir das an? Warum nicht?
Immer in die Fresse, genau.
Bruder muss los. Ich finde das gut.
Ganz ehrlich, ich fände
die Übersetzung mit Bruder muss los eigentlich cool.
Weil
ich glaube,
die werden ansonsten
das übelst cringe übersetzen.
So nach dem Motto
Unschallgeschwindigkeit
oder irgendwie sowas dummes.
Das sollen sie lieber sagen.
Bruder muss los.
Wusste gar nicht, dass du Farid
unterhörst.
Die Ärzte höre ich schon ewig.
Ich höre die Ärzte schon,
seit die Alben noch
indiziert wurden.
Was heute kein Mensch mehr interessiert.
Sag nur Geschwisterliebe.
Oder sowas in der Richtung.
Liege auf dir.
Du schreist jaaa.
Du hast mal vor x Jahren ein Lied von den Toten Hosen
auf YouTube kommentiert. Glaub hell nur.
Ja, hab ich.
Es gibt tatsächlich
auch von den Toten Hosen
ein paar ganz gute Sachen.
Der Schäferhunder, den finde ich
beknackt. War schon nie lustig.
Was kann man uns
der Linux Mint noch angucken?
Bisher muss ich sagen,
Elementary OS war die hübschere
rein optisch
die hübschere
Distro vielleicht
und auch eventuell
dass das
ein schöner
vorkonfigurierterer Gesamtpaket
aber insgesamt muss ich sagen
macht Linux Mint einen wirklich
ziemlich guten Eindruck.
Es ist alles dabei was man braucht.
Was haben wir denn sonst zu bieten?
Accessories.
Was hat er für ein Paket
für ein Kompressions-Dings?
X-Archiv? Ne, ganz normal.
Chrome Archive Manager
Ich hab da überhaupt nicht drauf geklickt.
Alter, Vmware
nicht rumspacken jetzt.
Ähm
Wahrscheinlich werde ich gehackt gerade
OMG Hacksaw
Gleich mal gucken
Gucken wir mal was
der Hacksaw treibt
Hier, der Hacksaw, was macht er?
Er macht
nix
Tja, dann scheint es wohl doch an Vmware zu liegen und nicht
dass ich gehacksawed bin
Na gut, auch ok
The System is up to date.
Mir gefällt das wirklich gut
So, was haben wir sonst noch dabei?
Ähm, Alter
Warum spackt denn die Maus hier gerade so rum?
Was ist das denn?
Archive Manager, Calculator
Okay, das ist der
Äh, Redshift ist glaube ich diese Geschichte mit
dass du es abends dunkler machen kannst, ne?
Was jetzt aber irgendwie
nix macht
War das nicht Redshift?
Wisst ihr was, Leute? Wir starten mal neu
Reboot
Weil wir haben Updates installiert. Schadet nie was.
Ja, dass der Bildschirm gelber wird
Das ist praktisch
Das nutze ich gern, sowas
Ups
Kann sein, dass es einen richtigen Grafiktreiber braucht
Ja, das ist möglich, dass es nicht funktioniert
Ja, wahrscheinlich wird es mit dem Vmware Grafiktreiber nicht funktionieren
Ist das hier Redshift, da unten?
Gucken wir mal
Äh
Wie findest du den jetzt mit?
Ich find's wirklich gut, gefällt mir echt
Hätte ich gar nicht mit gerechnet
Der Update sich mit ultra hässlicher Schrift
Aber das haben viele
Das hat viele ursprüngliche Windows Software
Hat hässliche Schriften unter Linux
Aber mir gefällt das wirklich ziemlich gut
Sehr nice
Huge, POC
Das sind, sag mal ich
Es geht nichts über i3, ja
Find ich auch
i3 beste, ich mein ganz ehrlich
Das ist schön für Leute, die Windows
Ähm, Windows Style Desktop mögen
Aber ich bin halt jemand
Ich bin halt jemand
Der will das besonders minimalistisch
Und Tastatur zentriert
Deswegen sieht mein Standard Desktop
Den ich unter Linux verwende auch so aus
Hast du einen bevorzugten
Windows Desktop Client für iOS?
Ne
Das ist mein
Ups, hab's verstellt
Das ist mein Desktop
Den ich auch auf der Arbeit verwende
Alles Tastatur steuerbar
Neue Anwendungen starten per Tastatur
Ähm
Ja, keine Ahnung
Anwendungen per Tastatur starten
Mit Autovervollständigungssuche
Mit den Quallen
Das ist ein wechselnder Hintergrund
Ich hab noch ein paar Hintergründe drin
Der Imagefont ist ein bisschen
Verkackt hier oben, seh ich gerade
Was ist eigentlich genau deine Arbeit?
Ausrufezeichen, Beruf
Da haben wir nämlich ein extra
Kommando schon für, weil das jedes Mal kommt
Die Frage, mehrfach
Profi ist auch toll, ja
Ich bin halt jemand
Der mag das minimalistisch, ja
Also
Ich versteh jeden, der sagt
Er hätte gern ein bisschen mehr Windows Style
So Windows, klassischen Windows Desktop Style
Ja, so mit Icons auf dem Desktop
Und Fenster, die man rumschieben kann
Und Fenster, die man
Minimieren, verkleinern und so
Aber ich bin halt jemand
Der steht auf
Tastaturbedienung
Desktop switchen
Per Tastatur
Ich mein im Prinzip
Ich brauche zu 90%
Zwei Anwendungen
Das ist mein Terminal und mein Webbrowser
Sonst brauch ich nix
Wie ist das eigentlich unter E3 WM mit Multi Monitor Setup?
Kein Problem
Das hat mit E3 gar nix zu tun
Das musst du halt von Hand machen
Musst du halt dein
Monitor Setup einstellen
Manchmal ist es ein bisschen nervig
Der ganze Minimalismus
Wenn man zum Beispiel mal
Seinen Notebook an Beamer anschließen muss
Ja, da muss man halt vorher gucken, dass man
Sich das passende
X-Render
Command hat
Aber für mich geht nix über
Guck mal
Ich hab mein eigenes Video
Geview boostet hier
Ich hab's
Ich hab's unter Linux fünffach refreshed
Weiß gar nicht, warum ich mein Video auf hab
Ah, das sind Comments
Das sind Comments, die gehen runter wie sonst was
Ich liebe einfach diese
Professionalität von Max
Man hört einfach raus, dass es sich in keinem Fall
Um Halbwissen handelt
So wie es bei anderen der Fall ist
Das ist doch was
Äh, ja, Chosen
Wenn du, je nachdem in welchem Bereich
Du unterwegs bist
Kannst du natürlich unter Linux vergessen
Fotobearbeitung zum Beispiel
Ist unter Linux ziemlicher Sack
Fotobearbeitung auch
Dafür
Dafür hat's halt in anderen Bereichen seine Stärke
Als Entwicklungsplattform für Software
Ist es meiner Meinung nach Windows haushoch
Überlegen
Außer halt für Windows Software
Siehst du großen Sinn darin
Wayland auf Wayland zu wechseln
Zum Beispiel auf Sway
Nee, weil's nicht richtig funktioniert
Ich hab's schon mal probiert
Vor nem Jahr oder so
Das hatte sogar Probleme Fenster zu resizen
Da hab ich mir gedacht
Den Scheiß geb ich mir nicht
Da warte ich nochmal 15 Jahre
Und dann ist es okay wahrscheinlich
Pog
Subscriber
Dankeschön
Windows sagt mit dem ganzen Update
Naja
Ich finde die Windows Update
Politik die sie jetzt fahren
Ist leider notwendiges Übel
Viele Leute haben Service Packs nicht installiert
Und hatten da auch keinen Bock drauf
Windows hatte nicht
Grundlos so einen unsicheren Ruf
Die Updates müssen unter Windows sein
Die Update Politik die sie fahren
Mit Zwangsupdates ist beknackt
Was war das für ein nettes LS
Das ist kein normales LS
Das ist EXA
Nennt sich das
EXA
Ist ein Fake LS
Vorher hatte ich immer LS
LS++
Das war ein Pearl Programm
Das war mir aber zu langsam
EXA beste
Da sieht sogar ein LS
In nem Directory Fancy aus
Und das wichtigste Programm
Ist immer noch das da
Bist du ein Keller gebräunter Computer Nerd
Aber sowas von
Ich bin huge braun
Bin ich
Bin richtig zu Lull schon
Ja zuverlässig Windows Update reverten
Wär nicht schlecht
Ja Chancen genau das ist das Problem
Was ich auch hab
Ich verwende Software
Unter Linux und Software unter Windows
Und für beides gibt es umgedreht
Teilweise keine Alternativen so richtig
Deswegen war die sinnvollste Variante für mich
Windows als Hauptsystem
Und Linux in der VM
Wenn man natürlich das Problem hat
Dass man sowohl Linux Programme
Als auch Windows Programme hat
Die irgendwelche Hardware Geschichten brauchen
Zugriff auf Grafikkarte für irgendwelche Render Geschichten
Dann tut es halt ne VM nicht
EXA ja genau
Du beherrschst Linux
Genauso wie Englisch
Kann man Englisch mit der Tastatur bedienen
LOLCAD in die Bash erzählen
LOLCAD ist eh das
Allerwichtigste
Äh
GPU Paththrough ist mittlerweile ziemlich gut
GPU Paththrough bringt dir allerdings nix
Wenn du VMware unter Windows verwendest
Ja die sind auch gut
Aber Dualboot geht mir auch auf den Sack
Deswegen für mich ist es so die
So die beste Variante
Windows mit nem Linux in der VM
Funktioniert für mich einfach am besten
Übrigens das ist das Programm
Hier was ich auf Fiverr beauftragt habe
Also im Prinzip
So steht das Fiverr Programm
Aus 50 Zeilen
C Sharp Code
Und aus
118 Zeilen
HTML
JavaScript
Und davon ist das meiste sogar noch Styling
Hast du auf der Arbeit auch Linux nativ?
Ja zum Glück
Zum Glück
Warum Dualboot scheiße?
Ja weil du immer alles beenden musst
Und neu starten musst
Also den Rechner
Programme kannst du ja wieder laden lassen
Wobei das auch teilweise nicht richtig funktioniert
Es ist halt einfach super easy
Desktop zu switchen
Und du bist von Windows in Linux drin
Da kommst du mit
Also den Komfort kommst du halt mit keinem Dualboot ran
Sind bei dir über
Mint YouTube Videos mit Mikro ruckeln versehen?
Ne allerdings
Ich hab Mint ja auch in der VM verwendet
Das heißt bei mir
Ist das komplette Decoding über die CPU gelaufen
In der VM
Da hat nix geruckelt
Kann aber durchaus sein dass es wenn du GPU Decoding machst
Halt wenn du es richtig auf deiner Kiste installiert hast
Das Mint dann ruckelt weil da Treiber rumspackt
Und läuft das Fiverr Programm?
Nö ich hab noch keine
Ich hab noch keine
Kein Code bekommen von dem Programm
Auf Fiverr
Also das ist ja
Das ist ja das was ich gebaut hab
Für hier Chat mit Schneiden
Und das gleiche hab ich auf Fiverr beauftragt
Dass sie auch sowas bauen
Weil ich gucken wollte was rauskommt
Schon WSL ausprobiert?
Ja
Geht in die richtige Richtung
Ist aber keine Alternative zu ner richtigen
Zu ner ordentlichen Linux VM
Oder zu ner ordentlichen Linux Installation
Fängt ja allein schon daran an
Dass du keine grafischen Programme richtig verwenden kannst
Du kannst zwar nen X-Server installieren für Windows
Aber versuch damit mal
Irgendwas zu machen was außer
Irgend paar statische Sachen rausgeht
Was natürlich richtig next level wär
Wine unter WSL
Das wär was oder?
Huge
Welche Codesprachen beherrschst du?
Oh da haben wir mal ne
Da haben wir mal ne
Ne Textdatei
Für gemacht
Wie hab ich denn die genannt?
Proggers?
Ja
Da haben wir mal ne Textdatei für gemacht
Weil das auch öfters als Frage kommt
Also meine Lieblingssprachen
Meine zwei Lieblingssprachen sind eindeutig
C-Sharp oder .NET und Ruby
Die kann ich auch alle Beide ziemlich gut
Python geht auch halbwegs so
Shell und Bash kann ich aufgrund dessen
Dass ich früher mal bei einem Hoster gearbeitet hab
Auch relativ gut
C++ ist geht so
Ich krieg damit Sachen gebacken allerdings hab ich da keinen Bock drauf
Assembler krieg ich rudimentär auch was zusammen gewurstet
Für Java
Nein Java hab ich da gar nicht aufgeführt
Java würd ich auch hinkriegen aber Java will ich nicht hinkriegen
Javascript, TypeScript
CSS, HTML
Ist auch ganz okay
Ich würd nicht sagen dass ich da wirklich extrem gut drinne bin
Aber passt ganz gut
Ruby krieg ich auch ganz gut hin
Das ist ja im Prinzip auch JVM Basis
PowerShell hab ich mal ein bisschen was mitgemacht
PHP hab ich auch ein bisschen was gemacht
Und Rust hab ich auch schon mal angeguckt
Da hab ich mir ne Weile
Gedanken zugemacht und ich glaube
Das sind alle Sprachen die ich kann
Bevorzugst du Vue gegenüber Angular und React
Ja hauptsächlich weil Vue super easy ist
Zum Einsteigen
Wie viel Geld hast du ausgeben
Du meinst auf Fiverr
Also 100€ oder so insgesamt
7 von 11
Haben abgesagt
Wollten das nicht programmieren
Und die anderen mal gucken was rauskommt
Der Fiverr Broadcast guckt meinen Stream
Ja das fänd ich interessant
Wenn der da gucken würde
Glaube ich aber eher nicht
Das waren alles Inder und Pakistaner
Zum größten Teil
Die ihre Programmierkünste
So günstig angeboten haben
Auf Fiverr
Ich glaub da ist keiner drin der
Deutsch versteht und Stream guckt
WSL2
Ja WSL2 bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf
Hast du Empfehlungen
Hast du einen VPN Killswitch
Unter Linux
Was genau willst du machen
Das
Das muss man mal erklären
Irgendwas was automatisch was beenden soll
Oder so
Glaubst du das Linux jemals Mainstream wird
Linux ist Mainstream
Linux ist fast überall Mainstream
Außer auf dem Desktop
Guck mal
Ok sagen wir mal so
Nicht nur Linux
Die Playstation hat als Betriebssystem
einen BSD drauf
Aber ansonsten
90% der Geräte
Wo man so tagtäglich
Direkt und indirekt verwendet
Werden wahrscheinlich
Linux oder BSD sein
Das iPhone ist BSD
Ganz ganz tief
Die Playstation ist BSD
Und
Die meisten anderen Sachen sind Linux
Was empfiehlst du als Grundlagen
Für jemand der auf Linux wechseln will
Gute Frage
Das einzige was ich empfehlen würde
Ist
Das man nicht denkt
Das es ein Windows ist mit anderer Oberfläche
Weil auch wenn sowas wie
Mint hier beispielsweise
Easy eats as fuck
Auch wenn sowas wie
Mint auf den ersten Blick
Ein bisschen aussieht wie ein Windows
Und wahrscheinlich gerade absichtlich
Ist es unter der Haube
Ein komplett anderes Betriebssystem
Was auch komplett anders funktioniert
In manchen Bereichen
Das einzige was man sich eigentlich merken muss
Ist das man nicht mit seinem Windows Wissen
An Linux drangeht
Und im Vergleich zu Windows
Wo viele Leute panische Angst vor einer
Kommandozeile haben
Was ich bis heute nicht so ganz verstehen kann
Wobei doch wenn ich mir Windows und Batch angucke
Kann ich das verstehen
Unter Linux darf man halt keine Angst vor einer Kommandozeile haben
Also
Sobald es ein bisschen spezifischer wird
Wird man über kurz oder lang da nicht dran vorbeikommen
Dann muss sich der Kasten auch mal
Also Shellscriptor werden oder so
Aber ein bisschen Kommandozeile muss sein
Unter Linux
Haben sie angegeben warum es nicht programmiert wurde
Auf Fiverr? Nö
Wirklich wir haben uns das ja vorhin angeguckt
Der eine hat es nicht verstanden
Der andere wollte 700 Euro für haben
Anstatt 22 was er haben wollte
Ursprünglich
Ja 700 Euro für 200 Zeilen
Lull
Der andere wollte 2 Euro für 200은
Er hat es nicht verstanden
Die anderen wollten 100 Euro
Die anderen waren zu unter der
1. Die 2.
Die 3.
Die 4.
Die 5.
Die 6.
Die 7.
Die 10.
Die 11.
Die 12.
Die 13.
Bin ich jetzt aber auch nicht so wild
Das glaube ich aber
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das hier mal sehen werden
Okay, er schreibt
Für einen Laptop
Ich möchte, dass mein VPN
Abkackt, das Internet ganz aus ist
Ich kein Internet habe
Nur um wieder zum VPN connecten zu können
Moment, was?
Du willst, dass wenn das VPN abkackt
Dass das Internet ausgeschaltet wird
Also du willst quasi alles durch den VPN Tunnel leiten
Oder wie?
Also du willst nicht aus Versehen
Sachen über das normale Internet schicken
Wenn das VPN abkackt
Hast du ein Modem oder kann das dein MikroTik Router?
Ne, ich habe das Unity Media Modem
Mein MikroTik Router routet halt einfach nur davor
Dahinter, hinter dem Modem
Hm, VPN?
Das ist eine gute Frage
Also ich meine, den kompletten
Traffic
Das klingt so ein bisschen, als willst du Dinge machen, die man nicht feststellen kann
Aber das ist ja dein Ding, kannst ja machen, was du willst
Ähm, also
Wenn du dann Default Route über das VPN machst
Also was
Du kannst ja bei OpenVPN, kannst ja einstellen
Dass du alles durch den Tunnel
Alles durch den Tunnel schleifen willst
Ähm
Hast du auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht das Problem
Dass Sachen vielleicht so ins Internet gehen
Wenn das VPN abkackt
Sicherzustellen, dass das
Da muss, da bin ich ehrlich gesagt überfragt
So aus dem Studio
Da muss ich mir
Das müsste ich mir erstmal Gedanken zu machen
Das kann man 100 pro einstellen
Das ist so eine typische Linux Geschichte
Wo ich dir sagen kann, das geht garantiert
Und wahrscheinlich, wenn man weiß, wie sogar auch relativ easy
Leider kann man
Schreibt der Twitch Zuschauer
Leider kann man mit Linux basierten Betriebssystemen
Nicht viele Top Titel zocken
Jedenfalls
War es so, wo ich das letzte Mal probiert habe
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass wir uns immer alle recht haben
Nein, das liegt an was anderem
Aber du hast recht, ja, aber das liegt an was anderem
Ja, aber das liegt an was anderem
Und ich glaube
Das ist einer der Punkte
Auch wenn ich glaube
Dass Google Stadia übelster Griff ins Klo wird
Und ich glaube, dass uns Google Stadia
Tatsächlich was bringen könnte
Für Spiele, die unter Linux laufen
Oder für Spiele, sag mal
Nee, nicht unbedingt für Spiele, die unter Linux laufen
Spiele, die nicht mehr auf Windows Only Technologie basieren
Ich glaube, da könnte uns Stadia
Wirklich was bringen
Ähm
Die Sache, warum Spiele heutzutage nicht
Unter Linux laufen, ist, dass wir uns Google Stadia
Unter Linux und anderen Betriebssystemen laufen
Ist hauptsächlich die
Weil die Sachen verwenden, die nur unter Windows da sind
Und keinen Bock haben
Die meisten Engines wie Unity und so würden es ja hergeben
Ein paar Anpassungen vorzunehmen
Für andere Betriebssysteme
Dadurch, dass allerdings Google Stadia
Die Server auch auf Linux Basis sind
Oder was, BSD?
Nee, ich glaube Linux Basis
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen
Dass die Anzahl der Spiele, die unter Linux läuft
Steigen wird, sobald
Sollte Stadia die Spiele auf Linux laufen, dann
Ja, irgendwie erfolgreich sein
Ja, und Anti-Cheat
Ist tatsächlich ein Problem
Wenn du manche Spiele unter Linux spielst
Kannst du ja sein, dass du als Cheaters
Erkannt wirst, oder aber
Die Anti-Cheat Software nicht funktioniert
Und dich erst gar nicht spielen lässt
Ja, Käpt'n Sieger, ich weiß was du meinst
Aber da fällt mir jetzt gerade nichts ein
Ähm, man bräuchte irgendeinen Hook
Man bräuchte irgendeinen Hook
So nach dem Motto, der mitkriegt
Wenn Interface, wenn VPN Interface
Down geht
Dann, ähm
Soll einfach den Default-Gate
Wenn ich will, ersetzen oder sowas
Wobei, der Hook an sich ist auch zu blöd
Du brauchst wirklich was, was
Was, was nicht parallel läuft
Sondern du bräuchtest wirklich den Hook, der quasi sagt
Der, oder der, der, der, der quasi
Läuft
Bevor das Interface richtig weg ist
Ich, müsste ich mir Gedanken zu machen
Wie man das schön umsetzt unter Linux
Stadia
Ja, wie soll ich es sonst aussprechen
Stadia, Stadia, Stadia, Stadia
Und Stadia, viel besser
Äh, Stadia wird in guter Google-Tradition in 3-4 Jahren eingestampft
Ja, gehe ich auch voll aus
Ich glaube, Stadia wird ein saumäßig großer Griff ins Klo werden
Es wäre cool
Also, ich fände es ganz cool, wenn sich das durchsetzen würde
Allein schon aus
Dass vielleicht mehr Spiele auf Linux laufen
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe es ja im letzten Stream gesagt
Stadia wird mich erst überzeugen
Wenn
Ein CS-Team
Mit Stadia einen Major gewinnt
Dann, dann bin ich überzeugt von Stadia
Stadia-Test im Stream
Ich habe es bestellt, ja
Ich habe mir
Letztens eine bestellt
Eine Founders Edition
Wir können das im Stream testen, ja
Ja
130 Euro fürs Klo wahrscheinlich
Was Tim Sweeney hasst
Linux einfach, wenn er meint
Es ist aber auch schwierig, ne
Anti-Cheat auf einer
Nicht-Native-Plattform
Weil
Vieles von dem sieht wahrscheinlich wirklich aus wie Cheats
Wenn es unter Windows laufen würde
Das Zeug huckt sich ja sonst wo rein
Also
Ich kann es verstehen, wenn man sagt
Dass
Multiplayer-Competitive-Spiele
Nichts unter einem anderen Betriebssystem
Als dem offiziellen Supporter gespielt werden
Das kann ich verstehen
Rein aus Cheater-Problematik
Ich meine, Linux mit den ganzen
Mit den ganzen
Ähm
Wine-Library-Geschichten
Ich meine, wer
Soll sich denn dann zum Beispiel dafür schützen
Eine gepatchte Wine-Version zu installieren
Die irgendwelche Cheat-Geschichten ermöglicht oder so
Das gibt, das gibt ein ganz großes Einfallstor
Max, ich habe auf Twitter gesehen
Hast du auch ein Anycubing in 3Megas
Bist du zufrieden?
Ja, ich bin sehr zufrieden mit eurem 3D-Drucker
Huge
Also für den Preis ist der wirklich nice, ne
Der hier
Ups
Teile gekauft
Ich habe ja, ich habe ja auch diesen
Diesen, äh
Ufo-Mod gemacht
Das mit der, mit der Lampe
Ja, der hier
Also das ist wirklich super
Ähm
Der kostet
Der war sogar billiger irgendwie
Da gibt es teilweise irgendwie 100, 160, 170 Euro
Und der 3D-Drucker ist wirklich cool
Also
Kann man empfehlen für den Preis
Hast du schon mal Solos Linux getestet?
Nein, habe ich noch
Aber den finde ich echt zu empfehlen
300 Euro?
28?
What?
Warum ist das so teuer?
Ich habe das für
Moment, ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken
Vielleicht habe ich euch ja auch gerade Mist erzählt
Wie viel habe ich denn dafür bezahlt?
Ich habe dafür bezahlt
Wo steht es denn?
Angaben zur Bestellung
Bestelldetails
Ich bin zu doof, das zu finden
200 Euro?
280?
280 habe ich bezahlt
Warum ist das Ding jetzt so übertrieben teuer?
Ah
Glaubst du auf Linux ist es erheblich schwerer ordentliches Anti-G zu machen?
Ja
Glaub ich
Unter Windows tauscht dir keiner irgendwelche Systemlibraries aus mit irgendwelchen gepatchten
Kram oder so?
Zumindest nicht der 015-Loop
Also ich denke Linux bietet mehr Möglichkeiten unter der Haube zu cheaten
Aber ich glaube eh, dass die Zukunft des Anti-Cheatings nicht mehr in besserer Anti-Cheat-Software liegt
Sondern ich denke, dass die Zukunft des Anti-Cheatings in KI-basierten Auswertungen von Spielestats liegt
Und ihr schreibt keine Lieder!
Weil du kannst Cheater, die quasi durch die Cheats besser sind, als sie sein sollen
Wahrscheinlich, denke ich mal, ganz gut mit Statistik-Auswertungen identifizieren
Penguin13, Twitch Prime, dankeschön
Nice
Gucken, dass ich nichts vergessen habe an Subs
Ne, habe ich nicht
Telekom launcht auch so ein Stadion
Ach stimmt, das wollten wir uns ja mal angucken
Magenta Gaming oder wie hieß das?
Magenta Game, nee wie hieß der Kram?
Ach doch, Magenta Gaming
Das wird auch so ein Rohrkrepierer, Leute
Wie gesagt, ich denke Stadia wird schon ein Rohrkrepierer
Aber Magenta Gaming wird nochmal ein...
Du müsst hier dann auch spielen, ja ja musst du
Kannst dich deine Steam-Library einfach importieren, so einfach ist das nicht
Der Johnson schreibt
Mir kam gerade der Gedanke, dass ich eine Windows-VRM unter Linux nutze, um ein paar Windows-Tools, die ich brauche zu nutzen
zu nutzen. Ich hatte bisher immer,
aber das Problem, dass VMs so
grottenschlecht laufen, am Ruckeln sind oder
sogar im Desktop-Browser-Betrieb. Gibt's da gute
Lösungen? Das Beste, finde ich, ist immer noch
Desktop-Virtualisierung ist VM bei Workstation
unter Linux.
Hast du die Chance mit KVM
eine VM zu betreiben, die
eine Grafikkarte durchgereicht hat?
Kannst du machen. Kann ja
auch wahrscheinlich die Onboard
Grafikkarte oder so sein.
Und das dann
abzugreifen und trotzdem in einem Fenster die Anzeigen
zu lassen, ohne einen extra Monitor mit
Glass. Das habe ich aber noch nie
gemacht. Mit Ruckeln Glass.
Ruckeln Glass
ist quasi ein Ding, was
aus deinen KVM
VMs das Bild von der
Grafikkarte abgreifen kann und in einem
extra Fenster rendern. So
abgedrehtes Geschiss gibt's ja nur unter Linux.
Also wenn du quasi eine
KVM, Windows VM unter Linux laufen
lassen würdest,
mit Grafikkarten-Pass-Through,
dann wäre das
eine Alternative.
Halt für Programme, die man unter Windows braucht.
Für Spiele, Competitive-Spiele
würde ich aber da auch nicht drüber spielen. Aber alles andere
sollte super benutzbar sein.
Ich komme mit dem Chat gerade nicht nach.
Nein, Solos-Linux habe ich schon nie probiert.
Ja, Rider.
Rider, gehen wir nicht auf den Keks.
CS analysiert schon die Demos
der Spiele mit KI. Würde mich nicht wundern.
Das halte ich auch für den
für die Zukunft, was
Anti-Cheating anbelangt.
Postleitzahl und Ort von Max League.
Warum? Weil ich wieder auf Amazon
gewesen bin.
Oh, fuck.
OMG.
League. Ach ja, genau.
Wir wollen jetzt zu Magenta Gaming.
Telekom starten. Übrigens, nice, wie viele Leute
dabei sind. Huge.
Magenta Gaming ermöglicht
Videospielen auf nahezu jeder Plattform.
Kommt, Leute. Wir haben gesagt, wir wollen
Linux Mint heute testen.
Da machen wir die Seite auch mal unter Mint auf.
Gucken wir uns mal an,
wie die Schrift so ist.
Darkseam überzeugt mich.
Allerdings schon mal.
Ayaya.
Neradon abonniert. Zwei Monate lang.
Ja, wenn er schon Ayaya schreibt.
CuteChat.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich könnte mal eine Runde Twitch Prime
Sub, äh, Twitch Prime ist ja laut machen, ne,
Leute, weil ihr wisst ja,
wer Amazon Prime hat, kann das Ganze
easy mit Twitch verbinden und einen Streamer
seiner Wahl kostenlos mit einem
Tier 1 Sub unterstützen. Euch kostet das gar nichts
extra.
Und für den Streamer ist das wie ein ganz normaler Sub.
Magenta Gaming ermöglicht Videospiele auf nahezu
jeder Plattform und Hardware.
Okay, bla bla bla bla bla.
Registrierung für die Beta-Phase startet am 24.
August mit mehr als 100 kostenlos verfügbar.
Was ist denn da drinne?
Worms 1 oder was?
Telekom Festnetz bietet ideale Voraussetzungen für
Cloud Gaming.
Fuck.
Wurde vor vor 14 Tagen abgeschaltet.
Aber das muss nämlich Unity Media auch funktionieren.
Mit Magenta Gaming
startet.
Ich, ich würde, ich melde mich da jetzt als Beta-Tester an.
Wie meldet man sich da als Beta?
Du achte, man braucht einen Telekom-Anschluss.
Kein Telekom-Kunde.
Moment, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Ich klicke auf kein Telekom-Kunde und soll mich dann mit Telekom-Login anmelden?
Huge Brain.
Ah.
Telekom-Logik.
Gut Leute, da kann ich mich nicht registrieren.
So, Registrierung.
Telekom, Mobilfunk.
Diese Stockfotos, Alter.
Okay, meinetwegen mag das kein Stockfoto sein, aber so diese...
Oh, im Hintergrund ist huge Grafik angesagt, wie man das hier schon mal sieht.
Ja, Field Card.
Oh ja, da hat ja schon die Welt drauf gewartet.
Diese...
Gibt es irgendjemand, der so schaut, wenn er Konsole spielt?
Und?
Und das Kind guckt sowieso so.
Alter, was für ein scheiß Foto, ey.
Gar viel Kart spielen die ganzen Pros, ja.
Sieht aus wie ein Playstation-Controller.
Okay, keine neue Hand verkaufen.
Aus über 100 Games wählen.
Nie wieder...
Ich hab das Gefühl, die Telekom...
Ich hab das...
Nee, also wisst ihr, ich glaube, irgendein Telekom-Manager
hat die Stadia-Präsentation gesehen
und hat gesagt,
Jungs, ich hab die Idee.
Wir machen Game-Streaming.
Und dann haben die Leute bei der Telekom
alle dann so gesagt, so irgendwie so.
Und der Manager-Typ hat trotzdem gesagt,
hier, Poggers, Leute, Game-Streaming, machen wir.
Und da kommt dann sowas bei raus.
Die beste Auswahl.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier zur Auswahl?
Gravel, hab ich schon nie gehört.
Das da kenn ich auch nicht.
Evoland.
Hab ich in meiner...
In meiner Merkliste von Steam.
Sniper Warrior.
Och, den Krempel da.
Hunting Simulator.
Asterix und Obelix XXL.
Also, man erkennt schon mal
einen absoluten Crap-Service dadurch,
dass sie quasi so als Headliner-Titel
Asterix und Obelix XXL 2 anbieten.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch zur Auswahl?
Kung Fu Rabbit.
Man kann den Kram übrigens nicht anklicken.
Pro-Sniper Warrior.
Cycling Manager.
Wird der immer besser.
Siberia.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Through the Woods.
Kenn ich nicht.
Criminal Minds.
Kenn ich auch nicht.
Shadow Combs.
Keine Ahnung.
Turm.
Das sagt mir irgendwas.
Das ist, glaube ich, relativ neu.
Okay, also.
Welche Spiele gibt's noch bei Magenta Gaming?
Beliebt.
Beliebt, ohne dass es den Service überhaupt gibt.
Okay.
Simon, das war's.
Das gibt's noch?
Railway Empire.
Project Highrise Moon.
Das wird ja immer schlimmer.
Project Hospital.
Das ist dieses Sim-Hospital-Clone, ne?
Igitt.
Die üblichen Abzock-Games.
World of Tanks.
World of Warships.
LOL.
King's Bounty.
Das ist auch irgendwie so ein Pay-to-Win-Mobile-Crap, oder?
Off-Road Drive.
Irgendwo dann diese Man of...
Das gibt's auch noch?
Man of War.
Collection Pack.
Was auch immer das ist.
Da ist ja 90%...
Äh...
Alt?
Oder...
Crap.
Der Switcher ist am Start.
Der Switcher 3.
Immerhin mal ein gescheites Game.
Pillars of Eternity ist auch gut.
Ganz viel Gesniper-Zeugs, was glaub ich vom deutschen Hersteller ist.
Uralte Flugsimulation.
Richtig uralt.
So 15 Jahre alt.
Da sind ja die richtigen Reißer dabei, die Titel.
Also die richtigen Blockbuster-Titel sind ja da dabei bei der Telekom, ne?
Huge.
Huge Gaming-Experience.
Best ever.
Was Kingdom Come ist dabei.
Ja, immerhin wenigstens ein gutes Game.
LOL.
LOL ist so ein Spiel, ne?
Auch wenn es jetzt nicht so vergleichend ist, sag man mal, von...
Was, was Aiming und Instant Reactions angeht wie CS, ja?
Aber es ist trotzdem ein Spiel, wo niemand mehr Latenz haben will als nötig.
Zumal LOL auf jeder Büchse läuft.
Die beste Auswahl, Leute, ist das.
Die beste Auswahl.
Die beste Auswahl aktueller Titel.
Also wenn das die beste Auswahl ist, aktueller Titel, also, keine Ahnung, wenn das die beste Auswahl ist, dann, dann mach ich die besten Reaction-Videos.
Nacho Libre sagt, läuft bei der Telekom immer so.
Nachdem AWS und Azure groß wurde, kam die Open Telekom Cloud.
Was?
Sowas gibt es?
Okay, das verwendet, glaube ich, wirklich kein Mensch.
Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ja, AWS.
Vor allem Azure ist ja wahnsinnig angesagt.
Auch zur Zeit.
Open Telekom Cloud habe ich noch nie gehört.
Der Magenta Sprachassistent.
Das ist doch was, das kennt doch...
Das kennt doch echt keine Sau.
Magenta Smart Speaker.
Ach du Scheiße, die Telekom.
Die sollen mal machen, was sie können.
Die sollen mal Glasfaserkabel verlegen.
Wobei, das können sie auch nicht.
Wir gucken uns da jetzt ein Video von an.
Das muss ich mir angucken.
Das müssen wir uns anschauen.
Magenta Sprach...
Oder Magenta...
Magenta Speak.
Äh.
Nein.
Sprachassistent.
Magenta Smart Home.
Sowas gibt es auch?
Oh Scheiße.
Magenta Smart...
Von der Computerbild auch noch.
Magenta...
Okay, das gibt es doch.
Magenta Smart Home.
Okay, Moment.
Ich muss mir jetzt erstmal den Magenta Sprachassistent...
Spachassistent angucken.
Da müssen...
Da müssen wir jetzt mal kurz...
Da muss Bela mal kurz die Klappe halten.
Ähm...
Haben die kein Werbevideo dafür?
Haben die da kein offizielles Werbevideo für?
Ich muss jetzt zugreifen.
Da muss es doch...
Da muss es doch Werbung für geben.
Smart Speaker.
Da gibt...
Da muss es doch ein offizielles Werbevideo für geben.
Ja.
Oder gibt es es...
Gibt es es schon nicht mehr?
Ah, hier.
Okay, mir hat einer ein Video geschickt.
Perfekt.
Forty.
Top.
Genau.
Es reicht jetzt nicht, dass nur Microsoft mitloggt, was du sagst.
Amazon mitloggt, was du sagst.
Google mitloggt, was du sagst.
Jetzt.
Die Telekom muss auch mitloggen, was du sagst.
Okay, also Leute.
Hallo Magenta.
Aktiviert...
Da hätte ich ja schon mal überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Ah, Leute.
Da hätte ich schon mal überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Durch die...
Durch die Wohnung zu schreien, Hallo Magenta.
Also, ich schreie auch nicht durch die Wohnung hier irgendwie, okay, Google oder so, aber...
Hallo Magenta, aktiviere die Situation Kinoabend.
Okay, ich habe die Situation Kinoabend aktiviert.
Oh Gott.
Hallo Magenta.
Vor allem, wer hat sich denn...
Hallo...
Hatten die keine Zeit, meine gescheite Spracherkennung zu...
Zu, zu, zu...
Hallo Magenta.
Ja, aktiviere die Situation...
Aktiviere die Situation?
Hätten sie nicht Szene nehmen können?
Aktiviere die Szene.
Oder irgendwas, was sich nach Deutsch anhört.
Abend.
Okay, ich habe...
Der guckt schon so nach dem Motto.
Wisst ihr, wie der guckt?
Der guckt so nach dem Motto.
Der guckt gerade seinen Kameramann an.
So nach dem Motto.
Wollen wir die Aufnahme wirklich nehmen?
Oder wollen wir das nochmal machen?
Wollen wir...
Wollen wir die Aufnahme wirklich nehmen?
So guckt der.
So, ich denke mal...
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Das wollen wir doch nicht nehmen.
Genau.
It was this moment.
He knew he was fucked.
Situation Kinoabend aktiviert.
Oh, ist das schlimm.
Smart Speaker sind generell keine Weltneuheit.
Aber ein Smart Speaker mit Sprachassistent aus Deutschland, für Deutschland, das ist neu.
Mir ist das scheißegal, ob das Ding aus Deutschland kommt oder nicht.
Es muss funktionieren mit Deutsch.
Obwohl der hergestellt wird, der kann auch in Togo, Togo and Tobago, oder wie das heißt, hergestellt werden.
Das ist mir egal.
Hauptsache, der funktioniert gut mit deutschen Sätzen.
Was sich ja nicht so anhört.
Ich meine, Hallo Magenta, aktiviere die Situation Kinoabend.
Und was der Smart Speaker der Telekom so alles drauf hat, und was das Besondere an ihm ist, das seht ihr heute bei den Netzgeschichten.
Ist das Video nicht richtig synchronisiert oder liegt das an meiner VM?
Ich glaube, das liegt an meiner VM.
Hallo Magenta.
Smart Speaker mit Sprachassistent aus Deutschland, für Deutschland, das ist neu.
Und was der Smart Speaker der Telekom so alles drauf hat und was das Besondere an ihm ist, das seht ihr heute bei den Netzgeschichten.
Ja, noch eben gerade schon mal.
Sicher und bequem.
Kein hin und herlaufen.
Keine Lichter.
Leute, aufpassen jetzt.
Die neuste Pleading Edge Innovation der Telekom aus Deutschland.
Keine Fernbedienung oder App.
Der Smart Speaker steuert auf Zuruf Telekom Dienste wie Smart Home oder Enter10TV.
Na dann probieren.
Telekom Smart Home.
Was ja auch übelst sacken soll.
Egal, ich halte jetzt mal die Klappe, sonst müssen wir uns anhören.
Oder App.
Der Smart Speaker steuert auf Zuruf Telekom Dienste wie Smart Home oder Enter10TV.
Na dann probieren wir doch mal aus, wie das funktioniert.
Hallo Magenta, mach mal das Wohnzimmerlicht an.
Erledigt.
Das klappt.
Ja, das ist ja auch eines der simpelsten Sachen ever.
Hallo Magenta, ich rufe bei Enter10TV nach Better Things.
Erledigt.
Tja, meine Serie ist schon mal auf.
Tippt der, tippt das Ding allen Ernstes die Buchstaben da gerade ein?
Habe ich das richtig gesehen?
Ich muss mein Headset wegmachen, sonst hätte ich euch zu laut ins Ohr geladen.
Lulve, alter.
Wublul.
Jetzt können wir unser E-Mode mal verwenden.
Das ist schlecht.
Okay.
Weiter.
It hört sich einfach gar nicht an.
Wublul.
Es tippt, es tippt wirklich, glaub es nicht.
Ich glaube das.
Meine Serie ist schonmal auf dem Bildschirm.
Ich frage mich.
Huge Subscriber, Kreelex, twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, Nice.
P fuego mal nebenbei kurzdessen ich keinen Sub übersehen habe?
Nein habe ich nicht.
conservationistdı dich um nicht auszulesen hat ein habe ich nicht alles gut weiter weiter
jetztindo edge 몇 von Ihnen an producesость dogg обратis zuicl近izicht transitioning
My Series ist schonmal auf dem Bildschirm.
Ja, meine Serie ist schon mal auf dem Bildschirm. Jetzt frage ich mich nur, wo Mirko bleibt.
Der wollte mich eigentlich auch noch vorbeikommen. Ich rufe den mal an.
Hallo Magenta, ruf bitte Mirko an.
Scheiße, wenn du Leute in der Adressliste drin hast, die vielleicht so ähnlich heißen oder du vielleicht zwei Leute kennst mit dem gleichen Vornamen.
Wird angerufen.
Ja, kein Problem. Ich habe es hier gemütlich. Ich gucke meine Serie. Alles gut.
Ja, bis gleich.
Doch, Telefonieren funktioniert also auch. Aber da geht doch noch mehr.
Neben den Steuerungsfunktionen der Telekom-Services bietet der Smart Speaker auch andere Anwendungen, wie die Abfrage des Wetters, das Erstellen und Verwalten einer To-Do- oder Shopping-Liste.
Oh, Leute. Beide Sachen. Beide Sachen. Wetter und To-Do.
Wetter und To-Do.
Ich weiß nicht. Ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass Wetter...
Wetter und To-Do. Beides quasi die Hello-Worlds der etwas fortgeschrittenen Programmierer sind.
Wetter und To-Do. Also alle, die über Hello-World raus sind und mal eine neue Programmiersprache ausprobieren, machen entweder eine To-Do-App oder eine Wetter-App.
Das macht ein Programmierer auf halber Arschbacke.
Das ist wirklich easy as fuck.
Wir haben sogar im Stream mal um irgendwie...
Äh, Blazer. Blazer zu testen.
Haben wir eine To-Do-App gebastelt in einem Framework, was ich im Leben noch nicht gesehen habe.
Das hat, keine Ahnung, eine Stunde gedauert.
Heratrix-LP, dankeschön.
Huge, huge brain.
Subscri... Ups. Falscher Knopf.
Subscriber.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt weiter.
Ja, bis gleich.
Stop. Telefonieren funktioniert also auch, aber...
Da geht noch was.
Neben dem...
Neben den Steuerungsfunktionen der Telekom-Services bietet der Smart-Speaker auch andere Anwendungen, wie die Abfrage des Wetters, das Erstellen und Verwalten einer To-Do- oder Shopping-Liste oder dem Abfragen von News.
Außerdem fungiert der Smart-Speaker auch als Lautsprecher.
Hallo, Magenta.
Also wenn ein Smart-Speaker nicht als Lautsprecher fungiert, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Spiele Radio.
Das ist der zuletzt gespielte Sender.
Alter, das sind die übelsten Scheiß-Basic-Funktionen.
Und das...
Vor allem kann das sogar mittlerweile jede 0815-Source-Spracherkennung.
Easy.
Hotword-Detection fertig.
Das ist easy as fuck mittlerweile.
Nicht das vom Scratch zu programmieren, sondern was zu verwenden, was schon da ist.
Zuletzt gespielte Sender.
Hallo, Magenta.
Stop.
Alter, was ist denn Musik?
Ja, Radio funktioniert also und der Sound stimmt auch.
Aber was passiert eigentlich mit den ganzen Sprachdaten, die hier von mir aufgenommen werden?
Na, die werdet ihr natürlich nie im Leben, auf gar keinen Fall, es ist...
Werdet ihr die speichern? Auf gar keinen Fall.
Nein, nie.
In Sachen Daten hat der Smart-Speaker einen entscheidenden Vorteil.
Denn er bietet sehr hohen Datenschutz nach den strengen deutschen Sicherheitsstandards der Telekom und der europäischen Datenschutzgruppe.
Da ist mein Vertrauen nicht so steil viel größer.
Es werden ausschließlich die Daten gespeichert, die den Betrieb des Geräts,
oder die Dienste des Smart-Speakers ermöglichen.
Außerdem hat der Kunde jederzeit das Recht, einzelne Daten oder auch komplett alle seine Daten zu löschen.
Die Daten werden natürlich nicht an Werbetreibende oder Dritte weitergegeben.
Hinten am Gerät gibt es außerdem einen Mute-Knopf.
Das heißt, ich kann jederzeit selbst bestimmen, wann das Gerät aufhören soll, mir zuzuhören.
Das ist die einzig sinnvolle Funktion,
die ich bisher in dem ganzen Video gehört habe.
Das Ding hat einen Mute-Knopf.
Ihr seht also, Smart-Speaker ist nicht gleich Smart-Speaker.
Wie sieht das denn bei euch aus?
Seid ihr Fans von diesen intelligenten Lautsprechern?
Die Telekom erklärt uns...
Leute, das müssen wir gucken, okay?
Wir gucken uns auch...
Die Telekom erklärt uns E-Sport.
Das müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Ja, das...
Da können wir uns nicht entgehen lassen.
Welche Funktion würdet ihr euch vielleicht noch wünschen?
Schreibt es gerne mal unten in die Kommentare.
Kanal abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Aber wenn TF jetzt mit Level 6 meine Lane gängt...
Oh Gott!
Das fängt ja schon an.
Ach du Scheiße!
Oh, das ist ein komischer Creative-Headset.
Nee, ein Sennheiser-Headset ist das.
Oder? Ist das ein Sennheiser-Headset?
Ich weiß nicht.
Irgend so ein Stelz-Bomber-Headset.
5, 3, 3, Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Gut.
Danke für den Sub.
Okay.
Moment.
Leute, ihr müsst...
Wir müssen stark sein.
Wir müssen...
Guckt euch die Bewertung an.
Wir müssen stark sein.
The Fr...
Frasier.
The Frasier?
Das kann nicht der originale Frasier sein.
Der Frasier.
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Dein Stream ist besser wie jedes TV-Programm.
Ich find's auch grad sehr unterhaltsam hier.
Okay, Leute.
Alter.
Joke.
Oder Joy Keel.
Dankeschön.
Twitch Prime.
Primers hier im Chat.
So viele Primers.
Huge Prime.
So, wir gucken uns das Cringe...
Das Cringe...
Telekom-Video an.
Okay.
Wir müssen jetzt stark sein.
Wenn TF jetzt mit Level 6 meine Lane gankt,
dann ist meine Lane lost.
Ja, jetzt ist Toni eh AFK.
Oh.
Da kann ich auch noch ein bisschen was moderieren.
Toni.
Ich mach nämlich gerade hier Sport.
Da ist sie, Toni.
Also, bam.
Elektronisch.
Bam, bam.
E-Sports ist in den letzten Jahren nämlich ein richtig großes Ding geworden.
Fans feiern ihre Lieblingsspieler wie Superstars.
Wie der Alltag eines professionellen Gamers aussieht und was E-Sports...
Der ist nicht mal ingame.
Ja, stimmt.
Der gankt überhaupt keine Lane gerade.
Außerdem gankt man keine Lanes.
Das weiß sogar ich als jemand, der nicht in der Lage ist, die Lane zu ganken.
Das weiß sogar ich als jemand, der noch nie LOL gespielt hat.
Man gankt Spieler und keine Lanes.
Wie der Alltag eines professionellen Gamers aussieht und was E-Sports mit Netzqualität zu tun hat,
das schauen wir uns heute an bei den Netzgeschichten.
Ausverkaufte Arenen, jubelnde Fans, sechsstellige Preisgelder und Millionen von Zuschauern bei den Lanes.
Ja, ja.
Wenn du Lanes gankst, heißt das aber, du gehst auf die Lane und gankst die Spieler in der Lane, oder?
Ich bin ja der huge big brain.
Moba-Spieler, ne?
Also ich hab da überhaupt keine Ahnung von.
Ja, siehste?
E-Sports brechen sämtliche Rekorde.
Diese Ausmaße sind doch der Wahnsinn, oder?
Wir sind heute zu Besuch beim SK Gaming Team.
Die Jungs spielen auf der Premier Tour das Spiel League of Legends.
Das Strategiespiel gehört übrigens zu den weltweit erfolgreichsten und meistgespielten E-Sports.
Wie gut ist das, klar?
In LOL?
Also ich meine, sind keine Koreaner, die können nicht übertrieben gut sein.
Aber wie sind die so?
Ja, außer Korea außen vor.
Wie sind die?
Geht so.
Ich glaub, viele andere aus Deutschland haben wir nicht, oder?
Ich kenn mich in Moba-Szene null aus.
Unterstützt wird das Team von der Telekom.
Ach, deswegen!
Ach, deswegen wird SK gezeigt.
Wichtiger sein als ein starkes Netz.
Von den Profis hab ich mir erklären lassen, worauf es tatsächlich ankommt.
Nämlich auf den sogenannten Ping.
Der Ping steht für die Zeit,
die die vom Spieler eingegebenen Daten bis zum Server und wieder zurück braucht.
Oh!
Das können zum Beispiel Charakterbewegungen oder Aktionen im Spiel sein.
Je niedriger der Wert, desto schneller der Abgleich mit dem Server.
Und desto größer der Vorteil gegenüber Spielern mit einem höheren Ping.
Die Grundlage für den Erfolg ist also, richtig, eine qualitativ hohe Netz-Performance.
Nun aber zu den Profis.
Wie seid ihr denn zum Gaming gekommen überhaupt?
Bei mir war es über die Schule.
Also meine Freunde haben mir das Spiel gezeigt.
Damals in der sechsten Klasse noch.
Dann haben wir einfach angefangen zusammen zu spielen.
Anfangs natürlich nicht bewusst, dass ich irgendwann mal professionell spielen kann.
Aber ja, ich bin...
Ob man viel verdient als deutscher LoL-Pro?
Ich meine, selbst die Koreaner verdienen jetzt im Vergleich zu anderen Spitzensportlern jetzt nicht irgendwie Millionen oder so.
Die Koreaner machen wahrscheinlich relativ viel drumherum.
Ich frag mich halt, wie es in Deutschland ist.
Einfach immer besser geworden über die Jahre.
Ich habe einfach immer weitergespielt.
Das Spiel hat mir immer mehr Spaß gemacht.
Und ja, irgendwann haben meine Freunde dann halt aufgehört.
Und ich dachte mir, wow, das macht mir immer noch mega Spaß.
Ich spiele weiter.
Und ja, dann bin ich halt immer höher und höher gekommen.
Und irgendwann kommen auch die Teamangebote.
Teams werden auf dich aufmerksam, wenn du weit oben bist.
Und ja, genau.
Gab es irgendwo einen Punkt, wo ihr gesagt habt, jetzt ist es nicht mehr Hobby, sondern wirklich irgendwie Job?
Ich finde, es ist schwierig, überhaupt Freizeit zu definieren.
Weil bevor man wirklich so das als Job gesehen hat, war das ja eigentlich so eine Freizeit, die man die ganze Zeit da reingesteckt hat.
Deswegen sehe ich das teilweise immer noch als Freizeit, weil es mir ja Spaß macht.
Es gibt allerdings natürlich auch Phasen, wo man nicht so Lust hat, vor allem auf Solo-Cue.
Also mit meinem Team machen ist eigentlich immer Spaß zu spielen, aber halt alleine.
Solo-Cue ist überall übelste Grenze.
Kann manchmal ein bisschen frustrierend sein.
Ist es denn wichtig, irgendeinen Ausgleich zu haben zum E-Sport?
Ja, also das ist schon sehr, sehr wichtig, damit auch der Geist so ein bisschen, man sagt ja, hält die Beine.
Das stimmt ja auch so ein bisschen.
Und deswegen gehe ich, also versuche ich zumindest so drei, vier Mal die Woche ins Fitnessstudio zu gehen.
Und sonst halt so ein paar Spaziergänge machen.
Boss-Transformation ist raus.
Oder halt so ein bisschen, keine Ahnung, einfach ein bisschen Ausgleich haben.
Ja, ist ganz gut.
Ihr seht also, Gaming macht eine ganze Menge Spaß, aber es kann auch echt ganz schön anstrengend sein.
Und genau deswegen...
Okay, der Beitrag ging doch sogar.
Ich meine, es ist ein Team, was von der Telekom gesponsert worden ist.
Die Telekom macht einen Werbebeitrag.
Warum nicht?
Ja, das ging doch noch.
Ja.
So, und jetzt wollten wir noch gucken.
Telekom Smart Home.
Ihr smartes Home.
Vorstellung aller Produkte.
Weil das gibt es schon vier Jahre.
Ich will mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Wie heißt das eigentlich?
Heißt das Magenta Smart Home?
Guckt mal das Video von der CSU.
Das haben wir vorgestern oder so schon geguckt.
Das war schon cringe genug.
Magenta Smart Home.
Da brauchst du unbedingt Magenta Smart Home für.
Und die Kaffeemaschine bindest du da nicht so ohne weiteres ein.
Das ist eine extra Magenta Home Kaffeemaschine.
Hast du einen festen Streamplan oder wenn Bock.
Der einzige feste Termin, wo wir immer streamen, ist Sonntag morgens.
Das sind ja die längsten 46 Sekunden, die ich je gesehen habe.
Ja, ist ein Schwachsinn.
Okay, erst in Richtung Smart Home.
Zeig mal her, Telekom.
Was habt ihr zu bieten?
Die Einrichtung von Smart Home erfolgt in fünf Schritten.
Oh ne, das ist langweilig.
Mit E-Mail und ...
Geh fort.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich mir diesen ganzen Crap von der Telekom holen sollte.
Es wirkt immer so wie gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
So nach dem Motto, Smart Home ist angesagt.
Ja, wir machen jetzt Smart Home.
Oh, Game Streaming ist angesagt.
Wir machen Magenta Gaming.
Oder, oh, Alexa ist angesagt.
Wir machen jetzt Magenta Smart Speaker.
Den Crap kauft wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal jemand.
Die Telekom sollte mal das machen, wofür sie da ist.
Und zwar mal endlich weiter Glasfaser verlegen.
Was hältst du von Telekom Car Connect?
Das habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Keine Ahnung.
Ist aber für mich auch irrelevant.
Ja, genau.
Das ist für die Alten ...
Das ist richtig, richtig KingWall.
Das ist für die Alten Rentner.
Rentner, die in den Telekom Store um 8 Uhr reintappen und sich das antreten lassen.
Exakt so sieht es aus.
Wahrscheinlich ist es unten drunter Tuya Cloud oder sowas.
Glasfaser ist neu, ja.
Ja, dazu fällt mir nur ein.
Glasfaser ist neu, dazu fällt mir nur er hier ein.
... sehr im Internet unterwegs bin.
Nicht so sehr mit ihnen und mit Twitter und so weiter.
Aber seit den 80er Jahren.
Wisst ihr?
Seit 1980 ist er im Internet unterwegs.
Ja?
Also von wegen, dass da noch mal irgendjemand Vorwürfe machen könnte, dass da irgendjemand keine Ahnung hat.
Seit 1980.
Der ist länger im Internet, als ich auf der Welt bin.
Ja?
Überlegt euch das mal.
Das ist der wahre Experte hier.
So fail, ah, so fail.
Wie lange bin ich denn eigentlich schon on?
3 Stunden 30.
Fuck, was ist da los?
Leute, ähm, eigentlich, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich erzählen soll.
Ich hab keinen Schimmer mehr.
Eigentlich bin ich, eigentlich bin ich fertig, ja.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich jemanden hosten kann.
Oh, da gibt's doch irgendwas, was wir uns angucken müssen, unbedingt.
Also wir haben jetzt, wir haben Linux Mint heute getestet.
Ich muss sagen, Linux Mint scheint mir eine wirklich super Distribution zu sein.
Für Leute, die ein bisschen Windows Style Desktop mögen.
Sehr rund, sehr, sehr schick.
Alles dabei, was man braucht.
Huge.
Ich hab noch nicht das Fiverr verpasst.
Naja, wie man es nimmt.
Also wir haben uns am Anfang ein bisschen was von Fiverr angeguckt, aber auch eigentlich nur die Leute, die abgesagt haben.
Ich hab noch keine, ich hab noch keinen Code bekommen von den Fiverr Leuten.
Bin ich noch eingeloggt?
Bin ich mal eingeloggt.
Nee, dann kann ich, kann ich jetzt nicht nachgucken.
Folge zu wenig deutschen Leuten auf Twitter.
Auf Twitch.
Weiß gar nicht, wie ich hosten soll immer.
Hier, Science Syntectology.
Wen haben wir da noch am Start gerade auf Deutsch?
Modpack, Tech Talk, Hacking lernen. Wie?
Code Linear war Zeug, CSGO Customing.
Wo?
Der Hacksaw.
Irgendwo auf einer anderen Maschine, sprich auf meinem Kali.
Auf Kali Linux hast du die richtigen Hacksaws.
Auf Kali Linux hast du die richtigen Hacksaws am Start.
Kali Linux, da gibt es eine lustige Geschichte dazu.
Das ist das letzte, was ich euch heute noch erzähle.
Auf der Arbeit hat mal einer Kali Linux installiert in einer VM.
Und weil er tatsächlich, sagen wir mal, er hat verschiedene Hacking Tools gebraucht hat, ja.
Weil er ein paar Sachen scannen wollte oder so.
Also nix.
Er hat ja auch eine Position gehabt, wo das okay ist.
Und auf einmal war sein Netzwerkport nicht mehr ab.
Und es kam irgendeine Sache.
Und es kam irgendein Security-Mensch reingewetzt und hat gemeint, was er da machen würde.
Da hat wohl irgendwelche Logs im Proxy.
Also wir haben so ein, darf ich sagen, was das ist?
Wir haben eine Antiviren-Software und Firewall, die quasi von dem Antiviren-Hersteller, die können auch Proxy scannen und so.
Und das Ding hat dann wohl gemeldet, dass da super krasse Hacksaw-Tools runtergeladen werden und jetzt muss alles gesperrt werden.
Dann haben sie übelst Panik geschoben, ja.
Welches Programm ist das linke in der Taskbar nochmal?
Ey, der Windows-Startknopf.
Ne, ich glaub nicht, dass du das meinst.
Was meinst du denn?
Das da.
Das da?
Du meinst das Grüne?
Warte mal, wer hat das gefragt?
Wer hat das gefragt?
Flintstone.
Das Half-Life-Symbol, meinst du das?
Das ist ein Kommandozeilen-Fenster.
Kommandozeilen-Fenster.
Das ist quasi ein Ersatz dafür, weil das Windows-Terminal überlebt.
Und das ist ganz gut.
Und das ist Chromium.
Ich habe keinen, den ich hosten kann heute.
Hm, wir gerne den Hexer eigentlich hosten gehen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich brauche einfach keinen.
Ich hoffe euch als Sinnen gefallen.
denkt dran
wenn ihr noch Primer-Subs zu verteilen habt
umso mehr Leute
subben, umso bigger
der IQ von allen, die zugucken
wir machen Schluss, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
morgen gibt es ein neues Video
ich bin auch gerade dabei
ich habe heute angefangen ein bisschen meinen Solverraum
umzubauen, ich habe gedacht
ich bin bis Mittwoch ganggeschrieben, kann ich wenigstens mal was sinnvolles machen
macht es gut
wir sehen uns, bis denn
see you